e
e e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
several bills to uh consider this today
uh in public hearing but before we get
to that I'd like to ask you to please
join me in the Pledge of Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank you everyone the first bill to
be heard today is house bills 576
FN and I would recognize the prime
sponsor representative Rosemary rang
welcome representative
run thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you committee for um uh allowing
me to introduce this bill for the record
my name is Rosemarie rung I represent
Hillsboro 12 which is the town of marac
and I distributed earlier um a text of
my remark so I'm not going to read it
but I do want to point out um the
impetus for this bill and it's I think
it's the third one that's been
introduced
um in the house to set up an ALS
registry um this bill um there's really
three drivers for this bill even though
I did say there's only two but I I added
one last night uh one is first of all
even though ALS is um a very uncommon
disease it is estimated that growth is
going to be 36% by 2040 in the US and
70% globally it's one of the most
expensive chronic diseases someone could
have um totally devastates quality of
life not only for the person suffering
from it but also their family and so to
really understand the impact of this um
and how it it may transpire in New
Hampshire in the future which would it's
also would take a lot of resources would
be just to count the cases we need to
know where we stand presently there's no
um
activity on the part of the state to
collect that information we have no clue
how many ALS cases there are although in
the um the bill that was U passed I mean
that that was introduced last year it
was um they it did uh estimate 26 cases
per year and that's aligned with the
national
average but my interest in this really
stems from the um cyanobacteria blooms
that we've been suffering in New
Hampshire um they've really ramped up
the last several years and research um
from around the globe is showing that
exposure to certain toxic cyanobacteria
blooms leads is a contributor to ALS um
I can go into the science of that but I
won't bore you all with it but there are
situations in areas um where
cyanobacteria a cyanobacteria toxin
called bmaa
um when that's prevalent there's also a
jump in ALS cases it was first
discovered in um the Pacific after World
War II when um this cyan bacteria was
found in a lot of the natural vegetation
that was consumed as food and then later
it was discovered around in Enfield New
Hampshire around Moma Lake that had been
impaired by cyanobacteria blooms a
cluster of ALS was found there and then
a couple years ago there was a cluster
found on the Eastern Shore of Lake
Champlain which has also been suffering
chronic cyanobacteria blooms so my
intent of this bill is really for New
Hampshire to start collecting data on
where we are now and to be able to
assess where we might be in the future
and how we should respond to that from
um a public health point of view and
also from an environmental point of view
it gives us more urgency to address
cyanobacteria blooms if we notice that
there is this public health issue with
ALS
um so I I looked at um our neighboring
states which have Registries Maine
Vermont and
Massachusetts and one of the things that
really glared out to me was and I and I
talked to the people that administer
those Registries is how much lower their
cost is for setting that up and
administering it compared to what is in
the fiscal note that DHHS
supplied um in in the fiscal note you'll
see that they've identified
$861,000 in the first year to count an
estimated 26 cases which is 33,000 over
$33,000 per case um I don't know about
you but that just seems a little bit of
overreach um they also mentioned in
their fiscal note that they quote expect
ALS diagnoses to be significantly
greater in number than those for the
other critical health problems listed in
statute
um f HB 576 am men's current statue that
only lists race syndrome and lead
poisoning as um critical health problems
Ray syndrome is has become extremely
rare when there was a jump in cases it
was due to um parents administering
aspirin to young children who had a
fever viral infection and with public
education about the hazards of that Ray
syndrome is very very very rare but lead
poisoning cases um this impacted more
than 1100 young New Hampshire children
just in
2023 so to think that ALS diagnosis are
going to be significantly greater than
lead poisoning cases just isn't true and
that's using the state's own information
and I incl I included the link in the um
in my handout I'll also email this to
you so you'll have the live link so um I
I ask that um you you pass this bill I I
would also ask that you question DHHS on
alternatives to the increased Staffing
that they're requesting in order to
administer this this program um I also
included um the information from the
other states um Vermont when they passed
it in
2023 at the very most they estimated
$75,000 to 100,000 to set up and
implemented in the first year
Massachusetts which has a far more
extensive registry where they contract
with neurologists to double check
diagnosis it's very intensive they spend
less than
$23,000 per year to manage its registry
so I'm not confident that the fiscal
note is an accurate representation of
what is needed to implement the addition
of ALS to the statute that which
currently counts race syndrome and lead
poisoning um and I do believe it's
important that we start collecting this
information because if the current
research continues to support the link
between ALS and cyanobacteria blooms
we're going to have to have some type of
a preparation on the part of the state
to address that so with that I'd be
happy to answer any questions okay thank
you any questions representative Weber
thank you and I I'm remembering that the
last time we saw this there was a um
suggestion that the registry created by
this legislation might be housed uh at
Dartmouth medical rather than in the
Department of Health and Human Services
and that that would get around the cost
issue um are you pursuing that or are
you considering having it simply be in
the department
itself um thank you very much for the
question representative Weber um I'm
suggesting that this be incorporated
within the Department of Health and
Human Services we already track over I
think two dozen C types of cancer we
track lead poisoning we have the ability
to collect data and actually I'm not
even um passionate about a full registry
I just want to get a count if we can
just count the ALS cases without any
type of information that would be
subject to Hippa um I think it's
important to get that Baseline I had a
conversation last year when after the um
this committee um I think they had
tabled the bill waiting to hear from
Dartmouth and then they eventually um
recommended it be inexpedient to
legislate at a conversation with Dr
Elijah STL who is one of the leading
researchers looking at um a variety of
neurological diseases and their
environmental triggers and he is a he
has a a neurology practice but he also
teaches at the geel school of medicine
at Dartmouth and he said Dartmouth would
not take this on um so it really should
be up to the other states uh it should
be up to the state just as our
neighboring states administer
it thank you representative McKay
thank you Mr
chairman um I'm concerned uh that we're
getting these this type of
legislation uh when it it appears that
the Department of Health and Human
Services is supposed to do this if they
see that it's uh
needed uh so that uh I'm wondering if
the oversight committee couldn't ask
them why this is is not uh being done uh
it it doesn't seem to to me that we we
should be telling professional groups
how to practice their in this instance
medicine uh do you have any comments
about how this this happens
frequently and any thoughts about it
thank you representative for the
question other states our neighboring
states have done it through legislation
um it hasn't just been left up to the
department to make the decision to begin
the registry because it does come at a
it it it comes at a a cost of time and
money to to do the administration some
software changes so I I do think it
should be a legislative decision to do
that um I think understanding the growth
in ALS diagnosis and it's linked to
environmental factors um it should be on
the state's radar um and hopefully
through these bills that come forward
even when they don't pass the increased
awareness and um the fact that we should
take a proactive approach to
anticipating what government needs might
be necessary should we see this growth
in ALS diagnosis it's it is one of the
most expensive diseases it it costs well
over a million dollars it's always fatal
um it puts a huge burden on families
because most of the the time they're the
ones providing the home health care
after the patient loses their ability to
perform the tasks of daily living so it
it is something that is in the best
interest of the state to start tracking
this um so that we're well prepared to
address any needs that come up in the
future follow up
followup my concern is why isn't the
Department of Health and Human Services
doing this representative McKay they are
going to be testifying next so maybe
good maybe they can help thank you that
answer I our representative mlan and
then representative
Nagel thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative R for taking my question
um so as you mentioned the Registries in
the other states are are quite expensive
extensive and you know Massachusetts you
said they're actually getting you know
data in from the neurologists so are
these not adequate enough to establish a
linkage for example with cyan blooms so
if we only have 26 cases what kind of
additional information specific we're
looking for specific information to New
Hampshire what are we trying to get out
of the commission or or the the registry
sorry that we're not getting from all of
these surrounding
Registries well geography number one I
think and well thank you for the
question representative um geography
number one I mean we may find that 26
cases are all in Meredith or all in bow
or all in communities Littleton for
instance which has a very impaired Lake
in its Community I think that's from my
perspective uh with CYO bacteria
research I think knowing the geography
of where those people reside or spend
most of their time is very important um
I also think that that geography could
give us information on where we need to
invest resources should we need to ramp
up our home health care
assistance uh careers in New Hampshire
and Staffing we may find that we may be
justified in setting up a program in The
Lakes Region to train people to take on
these tasks that are going to be at a
greater need thank you for the
question representative Nal thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um I have two related questions
is that okay sure is 2 a real number or
is that a statistical
number because interestingly the
statistics work out perfect if you look
nationally the rates per thousand
100,000 or whatever it it it is a
national rate so um it would really vary
I think depending on the community and
uh now in Vermont the first year they
had it it actually started in July and
from July to December they counted 27
cases um the the last year was its full
year and they counted I think about the
same 26 or
27 um I think it it's important for New
Hampshire to collect that information
because we have a much more robust Lake
economy and we have many people that
live along within Lake communities and
also people that come up and spend part
of the year in a lake community so I
think our situation is a little bit
different because of our geography in
our economy than if you compare it to
neighboring states does that answer your
question yeah so um my second question
is a little bit related but I tried to I
found it interesting where you tried to
put this in statute um I looked up what
a critical health problem was I couldn't
find a definition for it anywhere and
I'm curious is there a play where's this
coming from to Define this as a critical
health problem interesting enough um I
got a call after the last bill died from
someone who was retired from the
department and he had suggested to put
it in this area of Statute since we
already do it and there was no fiscal
note for those other two diseases thank
you representative
Maser yes thank you thank you for taking
my question I'm just looking at the
expend
expenditures um and so 8
61,000 and I'm looking at all of
the the jobs below that are listed down
below it
so I'm just I'm it seems like a lot of
money to to add one additional piece of
St statistics to what we keep track of
um like a quality assurance analyst so
that would be like a a
full-time job for the foreseeable future
is that correct yes thank you
representative I'm reading the fiscal
note the same way you are um it does say
five days per week for 26 weeks um I I
think that's a good question to ask the
department about the justification for
all these positions when an estimated 26
cases are going to be diagnosed right a
million dollars for that almost a
million is okay thank you
yes representative
Weber um no thank you so much and thank
you for taking my question
um so am I right to conclude from your
remarks that it's your opinion that
those numbers are grossly overinflated
for the number of for the amount of work
that you're
contemplating might happen and if you
would describe for us a little bit what
you think the infrastructure needs to be
in order to do what you have in mind
effectively thank you representative for
the question I am surprised at this
fiscal note I'm not an expert in
Registries or collecting health
information but when I look at our
neighboring states which um by most
counts we share a lot of the same
economic
features um really similar labor market
environmental
factors and they if we combined all of
their expenses for setting up and
conducting a registry all that combined
is less than what this fiscal no is so
it just raises a lot of questions in my
mind about what this is intended to do I
I would be very happy and I would kind
of say that researchers ALS researchers
and people looking into research with
the connection with cyano bacteria
toxins I think any information is
important information we have no idea in
the state of New Hampshire how many ALS
patients there are um I hear a lot of
anotal information about people on a
lake that have been diagnosed and so
forth but we need data and just counting
the number of if I would be happy if we
knew how many patients there were and
where they lived most of the year I
would be happy I think we need to start
somewhere and if we find that that count
is jumping well beyond what would be
statistically predicted um for our
numbers I think that may then you may
see us back or maybe the department
decides to expand the registry to
include more data but at this point I
think we need to get a good Baseline of
the number of cases we have in New
Hampshire and I think also that
information would be very helpful to
look in context with our neighboring
states thank you representative R um I
had a question you made references to
Lakes is that I I don't know a lot about
the disease I I I know it's also called
lugar's disease that's when it was first
discovered and I know a little bit about
the devastating effects it can have uh
from you know just reading and so forth
what is the lake connection is it um is
there a specific connection there or uh
yes thank you very much you may regret
me answering this question because I may
get into the weeds but stop me if I do
but New Hampshire has been suffering
from an increase in toxic cyanobacteria
blooms um and they hit primarily lakes
ponds and rivers
and these blooms there's the the water's
getting warmer there's a lot of
phosphorus nitrogen running off into
lakes and it's triggering these massive
Blooms of
cyanobacteria that are the world's
oldest living organism they enabled our
atmosphere to be formed um but when they
bloom they and it I want to back up a
little bit they used to be referred to
as blue green algae so if you've heard
of that that's the same as cyanobacteria
but these cyanobacteria they release
cyanotoxins and they fall into two
groups one that affects neuroproteins
and one that affects the liver and
there's been compelling research over
the past know over 10 well over 10 years
that one of the components of
cyanobacteria which is called bmaa it's
beta methyl Amino alanine that when that
is
ingested or inhaled by people that are
near a bloom you don't even have to be
in the water you can be out of the water
the body mistakes that for an amino acid
called el seering which the body uses to
synthesize
neuroproteins so instead of the El serin
going into the neuroprotein the bmaa
gets added and the activity or the
usefulness of proteins really is derived
from their three-dimensional geometry or
how they fold on themselves and when
neuroproteins that have mistakenly had
bmaa incorporated into them they misfold
and so they don't have the activity or
um they can't express their their their
biochemical purpose um as if they were
normally synthesized with
lerene scientists believe that this bmaa
getting incorporated into neuroproteins
and the
misfolding the misfunction that causes
in the neurological system is Manifest
itself with ALS it's there is also newer
research showing that it may also
contribute to Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's but that that research is is
still pretty
young thank you okay other
questions representative tez
uh thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you for uh explaining this to us I um
it's interesting I I'm looking up uh you
know when you said I would be happy with
just knowing the counts that raises
other opportunities like you know asking
insur like administrative data sets and
how many how many cases through
administrative you know which is through
insurers you know there there's other
ways we could try to just get
account um and that's different you know
then then there's surveillance which is
the public health system you know
monitoring and tracking and then there's
registry so so we we've we want to be
careful we're not
conflating um the different concepts
we're talking about um and I just looked
up there is a US registry but the
problem is when you look to see their
data it's from
2018 right it's there's a huge lag so I
can understand you're clearly in New
England there are more concerns I'm not
a question I'm sorry
um L my train of thought um uh well
would you would you be happy with just
would would it be sufficient to just
track
numbers uh like counts or is it really
we want to be able to know and manage
the
population thank you very much
representative for the question um
there's I I'm I'm hearing two different
things so correct me if I'm wrong but
one there is a National Registry but
it's voluntary so for real research
purposes it's not very useful because it
has that bias people that want to enter
their information enter it but we miss a
lot of cases because people may opt out
of that um as far
as what what type of surveillance or
collection of information we use
obviously I'd like to get information
that you know length of residency where
did you live maybe a occupation what
things might have you been exposed to so
that we can gather enough data to see if
there is something um environmental or
information that might help us address
any growth in ALS cases but at the very
minimum um for the purposes of just
knowing if there is a need we're going
to have to address in the
future just getting the number of cases
and where these people reside would be a
I think a good first
step thank you representative n thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question um I'm so impressed with your
description earlier that I'm a little
wild but I have a I have another
question um the importance of any
legislation is enforceability and um it
require this legislation I believe
requires that within 10 days you you if
I make a diagnosis that I have to submit
that
diagnosis um I'm curious what happens if
I don't do that and secondly um we
learned last time that a lot of the ALS
patients actually get their care in
Massachusetts not New Hampshire does
this apply to the docks in Massachusetts
that they're going to have to report
that to New
Hampshire thank you very much
representative that's a good
question I would have to go back I know
Vermont and in Maine and perhaps
Massachusetts um does address that issue
because there are a lot of verter who
come into Dartmouth they have an I think
they have an ALS clinic or well that Dr
stl's there he's like um so I think they
account for that but I'm not exactly
sure how that that administration of
people that go across state borders from
their state of residence how they get
that how that would be um accounted for
in New
Hampshire but I know other states have
done it so I think we could learn from
that and I'm also open I'm open to
Amendment like I said the very minimum
I'm really looking for is that we start
counting these cases and where the these
people spend most of their
time other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you very much
also signed up to speak is Whitney
Hammond from the Department of Health
and Human
Services and you've asked for five
minutes if you could keep a little
shorter that would be great maybe well
there two of you
so yes so yeah there's two of you so
okay that's fine I I can keep it brief
um representative rung did such an
excellent job communicating a lot of
what is in my written testimony so
instead of reading you know what I have
in there I'll just hit the key points
and then leave time for questions um so
I just first I'll introduce myself I'm
Whitney Hammond I'm the interm deputy
director for the division of Public
Health and I'm joined do you want to
thank you for the recer sorry my name is
Jaa Chala I'm the bureau chief of Public
Health statistic informatic in the
division of Public Health thank
you um so thank you for the opportunity
to testify today um the the the this
bill proposes an amendment to RSA 141 A2
to add ALS as a critical health problem
um that would require entities to as was
pointed out report ALS diagnosis within
10 days of a
diagnosis um the addition of ALS to that
statute would require us to update our
administrative rule so
hp32 which has uh
expired um the lapse occurred because of
um what representative of rung had
described which is that it related to
raise syndrome which is no long we see
about one to two cases of raise syndrome
per year as a country
um and then lead poisoning is covered
under a different statute um and so this
administrative rule hasn't been updated
largely due to the fact that lead
poisoning is covered in other
statute um the amount of time it would
take for the Department to update those
administrative rules would likely be
around 6 to 8 months as opposed to the
60 days that's in the proposed
legislation um the other noteworthy
thing uh and it is in my testimony but
regarding some of the questions that
came up uh during representative Run's
testimony we don't currently have so if
you're familiar with the critical health
problem um statute it was
developed I think back in the 70s um so
there is no actual infrastructure in
place to facilitate the reporting of
those critical health problems um so
there there's no data system there's no
existing staff um in terms of raise
syndrome so the department would
actually need to develop uh an
information system that's hippoc
compliant and that is you know going to
keep all of that data safe and secure um
so that ties into some of that fiscal
note worksheet in terms of the if you
see the cost by year it's it's a big
cost in the first year and then it drops
down to Staffing costs in the subsequent
years so it is really important to have
that context of this isn't adding in a a
critical health problem to an existing
data infrastructure um we would have to
develop
that um and then the other
noteworthy thing I I think actually that
is the the most important thing so time
frame for updating administrative rules
would not work within 60 days and there
would be a big upfront cost for
developing an ual
system happy to take any
questions great um and um ma'am could
you give us spell your name for us
please uh Jala c h i a h UI last name c
h h UI yeah last name c h a w l a c h a
w l a yeah thank you okay
if you can read
that i a h yeah okay great thank you
very
much uh uh representative woods and then
representative Weber thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
I'm a little bit confused you identified
that there is no system
present um does that mean you're not
tracking lead as well so there is a lead
system specific there is a system yeah
there is a data system for lead that's
covered under a different RSA which I
referenced in my written testimony um
but that would be very specific to
capturing lead data and not ALS data um
and predominantly the reporters for lead
poisoning are Labs as opposed to
provider you know Primary Care
neurologists follow followup
um I know I'm very naive perhaps but it
seems like that
system uh in place for lead would be
would interface very easily again my
naive perspective uh to handle uh
something like a the ALS
data I can take that question thank you
for that question so currently for lab
poisoning and lab testing we do have
other mechanism and under other
administrative rules to identify what
data element to um collect and and the
frequency and who should report so that
is covered under um the healthy home or
lab poisoning programs uh administrative
rules so for that system we will need to
do more uh investigation and and
identify whether that system will be
able to be expand to include um other
critical uh health problems like AOS
into that system but typically the
reporting stream is from um different
um healthare providers uh primary would
be like a pediatrician or um lab system
to report the that poisoning testing
result to that system uh so that is what
I understand the other part is the data
elements are different So currently um
the lad poisoning is follow is following
our New Hampshire implementation Guide
local implementation guide to uh submit
the lab poisoning testing result data uh
the data element may not be um similar
with what the health uh Records or or um
health conditions will need to provide
it so so we will need to do further
investigation and and talk with the
program areas and also our it folks
whether that channel is feasible or not
but basically those are two different
Reporting System uh per different
program needs and
requirements thank you representative
Weber and then representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman well having
answered representative Wood's question
you answered my first question but
brought up another question which is um
with respect to rul making I understand
that if we were to keep the bill as it
is it's in a section that already
requires rul making from the Department
with respect to any disease that's added
to that
section could we not not put this in a
freestanding section somewhere else and
simply
require
that Physicians report to the
department the minimum amount of
information which is the the presence of
the disease and where the person
lives uh which certainly in my mind
would not require rule making at all it
would simply require a secure location
to put the data but that's not a huge
amount
of that's not a huge amount of
recordkeeping what would be the barrier
to doing that at a very minimum level at
a very minimum cost so we could figure
out whether such information as as basic
as GE we've estimated ated
26 um cases per year based on National
Data but Vermont which has a population
less than half of ours already has about
that many so we don't even know where we
fall in that Spectrum what would be the
barrier to doing that very very minimal
amount of data
collection so I want to make sure I'm
understanding so are you saying instead
of what's in the proposed bill which
would make um ALS a critical health
problem just add another um like ALS not
CR okay um I would think and I would ask
jawe for her um input because she works
in this more than I do I think that
would require administrative rules for
the Department to you know once if um
could you speak the current uh statute
does say that rule making on the
administrative rules and the current
statute also um identified that the
department would need to identify the
data element on the collection which
include the social security number
currently is listed as one of data
element and uh for the Department um is
a kppa cover entity so we will need to
fall under the Hippa uh compliance to
make sure that the system Safeguard all
the Phi pii as well so for that sense um
that's why in our physical node we
consulted with our it folks to utilize
the current state infrastructure which
we have which is a Salesforce
infrastructure and because we do not
have this administrative rule so we are
not sure what the minimum business
requirements are for example what type
of data elements we will need to collect
what is the validation process would be
needed in order to collect the uh
validate and useful data set we do not
want to have anyone to open we do not
want to open a form to have anyone to
report we want to make sure this is
reported by the provider who does the
diagnosis to a specific patient and also
um uh without the administrative rule or
without the business requirement it
would be a little bit difficult for a it
system to be established uh and also um
to look for a meaningful way to validate
and also to um uh quality control the
data entry and as well as the follow-up
reporting so that's why in our um fiscal
note we put estimate we do not want to
underestimate the system because if the
requirement is a little bit complicated
uh not only to have the providers to um
report the cases but also to verify the
provider's identity which might lead us
to um work with oplc office or
professional license um sorry I forgot
what is stand for uh that that type to
verify the uh provider's status and
identify who will need to report rep and
if someone does not report we may need
to follow up but what we base on to
follow up with a provider that's
something that we also need to have a
good um requirement uh in beforehand
when we establish a system so that's why
and administrative rules will really
help uh IR out the basic requirement
follow up thank you very much and I
understand the complexity as it relates
to the bill is drafted what I'm really
asking
and this is because I'm not a health
care professional but I have done a
great deal of Investigation of a lot of
different things in the course of my
lifetime and it seems to me and I also
do know because I am a lawyer that we
often have statutes that are not
accompanied by administrative rules
because the statute tells you exactly
who is going to do what and so it seems
to me that it could be possible to draft
a statute
to minimize the burden on the
department could we not simply have a
statute that says a provider who
diagnoses this
disease shall report it to the
department and the department will keep
records
of the the the patient the location the
patient lives in and um we'll keep
records on the number of cases so we're
not getting
into huge privacy issues it then seems
to me that that's just a matter of
collecting the information that comes in
and wouldn't it be true that somebody
yes would be required to call and verify
perhaps that this was a licensed
provider but that that's a very minimal
amount of effort on the part of the
department and I'm not understanding
what I'm missing here so I'm hoping you
will explain that to
me um yes I I agree that if we have
everything ly out on the administrative
excuse me the statute excuse me uh
including the data elements that we will
need to collect then that that would
help us on the it side um to be able to
identify the business need and then
identify the C for the infrastructure
building and development that is fible
but uh um I'll defer it to when if from
the Department perspective or from the
um legislative pers yeah I would I would
agree with what um she said
um I'm trying to think through the the
question around
Hippa um and just
I I think in order to be able to do some
of the like quality assurance and
verification and I I'm not expert in
Hippa but I I think it would be
challenging to have high quality data
that is not going to also need to be
Hippa compliant if that makes sense like
I I don't think um it would be as simple
as like somebody saying hey I've got one
put it on you know put a check for what
I think we would want a little more
detail to be able to make sure it's not
the same one that we got a report on
from another
provider um
and so yeah thank you thank you that Mak
sense representative McKay did you have
your hand up a moment ago and then
representative L mantin thank you Mr
chairman uh I have uh no concern about
this
legislation uh what my
suggestion is that this could have been
handled uh by the oversight committee
the legislative oversight committee that
was established for these purposes there
are a couple of people in this room
right now I think that serve on that
committee is it your opinion that the
oversight committee which meets
frequently probably monthly monthly uh
uh and the chairman is one of those
people uh it's a very effective group
my point is that it it need not have
come to us at all it could have been uh
worked on by the existing system that is
here do you have any thoughts about
that so my read of the current statute
around the critical health problems is
there there are so there's the lead
poisoning requirement the race syndrome
and then there's a third um broader
category for critical health problems
that are identified by the department so
I think in in that regard ALS could be
um identified as a critical health
problem under existing statute I I do
think you know and based on the fiscal
note worksheet there would have to be
resources allocated to support the
department and being able to
operationalize that so in statute yes
but it does need resources allocated
follow up follow up
my major point is
efficiency and the legislature formed a
committee to do the things that we're
doing right now uh and I'm kind of
putting you on the spot by saying if it
couldn't this have been all worked out
already without coming to us at
all I'm not familiar enough with the
so I'm not familiar enough with how the
oversight committee would come like how
this would actually be brought to them
in the absence of this proposed
legislation representative lamon and
then representative mlan thank you Mr
chair and thank you for um taking my
question um but it seems to me that the
difference between a registry which
which records um name and data um would
be different than just keeping a list
because first it'll allow perhaps the
CDC to cross check that we're not
recording the same patient that in New
Hampshire that goes to Dartmouth or in
Massachusetts um that would it would
give you a better account um but it
would be also true that with that
registry um the CDC or perhaps other
researchers may be able to contact and
request permission from the patient to
participate in more long-term studies or
looking back because maybe it is cyano
bacteria but maybe it was an exposure
that occurred 20 years before they could
could collect all that data of where
people lived in the past and and maybe
find clusters because ALS you know
unlike lead
poisoning um which has a known cause we
don't know what causes it and there's no
cure and only by really being able to
get into long-term studies and knowing
all the patients who they are and where
they lived would be able to make
progress in that area is that right yeah
um thank you for making that distinction
around a registry and collecting case
counts um and I do think that is a
fundamental question of what is it that
we want to be able to do related to ALS
that should then guide what is the
solution that we need in New Hampshire
to be able to achieve that and even just
hearing some of the description around
you know well it would be good to have
residential history and know how often
people are you know in places on lakes
in New Hampshire that starts to get into
a much bigger sort of system that's more
registry esque than counting cases and I
think you make a nice uh point about how
public health uses the data also in
impacts the way that we design the data
collection so for something like lead
poisoning it is enough to just have you
know that that data and be able to
actually provide case management for a
child who has elevated blood Le levels
but it's not necessarily you know useful
for connecting them with
research representative
McLean thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so I'm not in house
finance but obviously the sticker shock
on this bill is is pretty big but that
being said it sounds like this is the
first critical health problem that we're
looking at as to representative Wood's
comments so do we see a horizon where
we're going to be wanting to look at
other critical health problems is is
there other things that the the
department is looking at and with that
being said you know if we do this work
now and develop this registry having
established that framework is as we add
on these new critical health problems is
it a zero costing or um you know because
or is it is it going to be $800,000
every time okay it's a really
interesting question and I will ask for
JA way to weigh in but I would say just
from my work in chronic disease more
broadly and The Division I would I would
absolutely anticipate additional
interest in adding other critical health
problems when and if the infrastructure
was in place around ALS so we frequently
receive questions about other kinds of
chronic conditions that I could imagine
people having interest in but the follow
on cost would be that's where I would
ask for ja's input that that will
actually depends because each disease
has different um Specialties or uh staff
you know specialty to to be able to do
the followup working a registry um so
that that will really depends on which
disease that we are we are tracking and
for the record we are we do um receive
the the lab poisoning um test result
under this statute uh but under the
other administrative rules so alsos will
not be the first critical conditions
under the statutes that we are currently
we will be receiving so left poisoning
is part of part of then that we the
department is working on now so um
theoretically yes but it depends on the
business need and if there are any other
um type of informations that the
registry of specific uh disease is
looking for that then that may or may
not that may add some additional CA um
the current infrastructure uh or create
different module because
we may want to have some kind like a
user access restriction even though it's
one registry or even though this is a
registry but this is for ALS registry
certain users may not be able to see the
information from other registry or from
other disease so they will have a more
further discussion on uh not only um to
create module for another disease but
also how we do uh good in the data
governance and data management for the
user access and Reporting access Channel
Etc so at this moment um it may have
additional cost yes follow up and thank
you for that but just as a followup
though would this system though once
it's established be the basic framework
in so you're not going to be creating
separate Frameworks this is everything
is going to be added onto this we're not
going to be creating SE separate ones in
the future just adding in and modifying
it slightly to adapt for different kinds
of problems
uh thank thank you for the follow-up
questions um
theoretically yes but uh uh we will
still need to see what type of disease
will be added and if there's any
additional um requirement that would be
needed uh then then that could have
additional cost at this moment we are
not able to uh provide a certain
statement that it yes or no on the cost
sorry thank you I'm repres ative n thank
you Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question um I brought this question up
earlier but interestingly I'm on the
rare disease commission Believe It or
Not ALS is considered part of that does
a condition that affects 26 people or
diagnoses per year 66 total in the state
um does the department consider that a
health care um crisis or whatever are
whatever term I'm sorry the critical
health problem critical health problem
um I had opened the definition from
statute of a critical health problem a
disease condition or procedure relating
to Public Health which is determined by
the commissioner to be of particular
concern or importance as a critical
health problem in this state being in
need of Greater research study and
statistical analysis that seemed very
open-ended to me and I looked for more
of a national um definition and I
couldn't find one so I'm just curious
would you guys consider that to be a
critical health problem if it affects
that few
people I don't
different um and I don't think there's
more clarity in the administrative rules
around this so I I would say I don't
know how to define a critical health
problem without more
definition okay thank you representative
taes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions um
uh I I I really appreciated some of the
prior questions and I feel like
representative Weber laid out like
what's the right process but also we
explored is there another data system to
build on and so part of what I think I'm
not completely clear on is are there
other reportable conditions are there
other like are there other systems that
exist already because I think that was
the point of the question is is there
anything else we could build on because
we don't know right like maybe there's
10 other potential systems we could be
building on we just picked the one that
has lead or or whatever so I think that
would be a a helpful thing to understand
um so yes there are many other systems
for reporting all kinds of different um
data to the department like for example
the cancer registry or we have our
communicable disease reporting which is
a very different approach for how we
gather data so I think in answer to your
question it could be worthwhile to look
at what we have in place and how we
could build on something that's already
existing I would add though the you know
the point around that may have a cost
associated with it to to sort of
retrofit an existing system but we'd
have to look into that follow up follow
up yeah so thank you I think you did a
lovely job of explaining like
potentially the huge costs in the first
six months although it sounds like maybe
it's lot less right depending on the
answer to all these other questions I am
more wondering about the need for one
FTE every year thereafter for a
condition that maybe you know you know
is is a much
slower prevalence in incidents so can
you speak to that
please I don't so I think it would take
around one FTE to be look certainly in
the first year helping to get things up
and running the fiscal note worksheet
included um costs related to contractors
who would work on development of the
actual system and there would be the
need for somebody to be overseeing that
work and monitoring it and then moving
forward I think especially with
something this new there would be a need
to have um probably one FTE to just even
be working with providers and promoting
the the reporting into the system and uh
presumably there would actually be
requests to use the data in the system
and so we would want somebody available
to be responding to that as well just
for context um the cancer registry has
about I think 10 full-time staff that
and clearly there are more cancer
diagnoses than ALS but there's a lot of
support for providers and offices around
giving us this data because it is um you
know something that's additional for
them to do and particularly if you want
something like residential history
that's not something they're typically
collecting as part of their electronic
health record so that individual who's
one FTE would also have to be doing work
with providers to help them capture the
data we
want any other
questions sorry uh may I oh sure sorry
follow up the questions um during the
questions we did hear that how the data
will be used um I just want to mention
that we the department do need to have a
legal Authority in order to release the
data that we collect currently this
statute does not give us any legal
Authority other than uh release the
aggregate annual report so if the intent
for this ALS data is for research we
will need to have legal Authority on how
we should release the confidential data
and maybe have um a a privacy review
board uh to review all the uh
applications uh I just want to uh put
that uh in the front uh if if there's a
um expectation or if the statute will
require the department to release the
data for the research for the health
related research purpose then we will
need to have the legal Authority in
order to do
so thank
you I see no other questions so thank
you very much thank you
also signed up to speak is Nancy Beerman
representing herself in Our
Deck you didn't indicate how much time
if we do about three minutes would be
great I'll
try every committee I testify in front
just announces you only have this much
time um yes Nancy Beerman um I'm on the
rare disease advisory Council for New
Hampshire um with representative Nagel
um and uh we uh also I'm here also to
introduce us in case you didn't know
about our Council um and also let you
know that we are available to testify
and give um information and give you
more um data on what's going on um Dr
um where is Elijah STL is also on our
committee in fact it's was part of the
uh beginning of the rare disease
advisory Council that someone from the
ALS with research was part of the
committee um just to let you know rare
diseases less than um one and 2,000
people are diagnosed with it and that's
what you need to be considered to be a
rare disease there's over 300 million
people in the world that have a rare
disease that means 3.5 to 5.9% of the
population have a rare disease 72% are
genetic
diseases 70% of them start in
childhood but it will take almost up to
10 years for most people to be diagnosed
um my child has multiple rare diseases I
had had one it's now been not deemed
rare um uh because of the number of
people that are recently being diagnosed
with it and more awareness of it uh my
mother has one um that's different um
than what my child has and I may acquire
it at some point um all pediatric
cancers are rare um also to let you know
rare disease today day is February 28th
and we are going to be trying to be here
to bring
awareness um the uh rare disease
advisory Council was formed in 2019 here
in New Hampshire um this year I was
fortunate to be able to travel to
Washington DC for the National
Organization of rare diseases um and
meet with other arxs um around the
United States not every state has one we
are one of the beginning ones um and uh
one of our we have an RSA 126 a79 and uh
one of our mandates is to collect data
and explore data collected by the
Department of Human Services so
representative M Clean yes there are
many of us that would like to add more
rare diseases to a registry to find out
exactly what is going on um for my own
child yes her genetic disease showed up
at BIR
um but it took until the age of 14 to
get a diagnosis I knew there was
something up I knew something was wrong
I didn't know what it was I knew there
was stuff going on in my whole family I
mean I just thought it was normal that
every family had all kinds of medical
issues I later found out that isn't
normal um you know when we finally got
her diagnosis it's like oh you all have
it so I felt like I was Oprah you have
it and you have it and you have it to
all our family members at Christmas one
year once we found out what it was um
but also getting um access to genetic
counselors and information is very
difficult and having a rare disease it's
hard to find doctors um we spend our
days and weeks in Massachusetts
traveling down there to get to experts
because they don't exist here in New
Hampshire so um uh the rare disease
advisory Council would definitely
support this bill and trying to get a
registry and also to add other um rare
diseases to be tracked because a lot of
rare diseases are going off of the list
of being rare and becoming more and more
common thank you any questions any
questions representative nan oh hi thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
questions nice to see you again nice to
see you um You' said something really
interesting several times that your rare
disease is no longer rare why do you
think that is um because of the uh
leader uh of that's been doing all the
research um he stated last year that
it's no longer considered rare with the
number of people that are being
diagnosed with it so um statistically I
don't have the numbers I'm not a math
person but just with the number that's
coming up and one of my other uh one of
my daughter's other rare diseases were I
know social media is not the best data
collection but um we have people on
there from all over the world and when
we're getting two to three new people
joining and saying hey I just was
diagnosed with this that's
alarming and um and people are looking
for help looking for answers how do I
treat this how do I keep my two-year-old
safe and um the disease I'm talking
about is called uticaria and um we've
had a lot of new diagnosises and um and
it's alarming the number of children and
little ones um that are being diagnosed
and it's dangerous um you can go into
anaphylaxis and you can die very quickly
from this because if you're not aware of
it and other people aren't aware aare of
it and doctors will just tell parents oh
you don't need an upy pen it's no big
deal it is a big deal um if they're
exposed to cold and you don't even know
what's going to trigger it it can be the
air it can be the water it can be air
conditioning it can be a difference in
temperature my daughter's first
experience was at Lake Sunapee in the
summer um that's not a cold time of the
year um and uh you just don't ever know
what's going to trigger it and when you
have Littles that don't tell what's
going on and how they're feeling because
they don't know that it's different it's
very dangerous and we've had quite a few
parents like oh my gosh we ended up in
the emergency room and I had no idea and
so they're sharing the symptoms that
their child had in order to let other
parents know hey if your kid acts like
this after being out in the cold or
being exposed to cold it also is eating
cold things try to tell a 5-year-old you
can't have ice cream not easy um so you
you have to be very aware of anything
and everything that can be that can
trigger that disease and we're all
different and we all react differently
and you know some of them they can't
even take a shower they take a shower
and they get out of the shower and they
have a
reaction thank you any other questions
thanks seeing none thank you very much
thank
you hey no one else has signed up to
testify on HB 576 FN so I am going to
close the public hearing on that bill
and open the public hearing on H h b
634 and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Stringham I thank you
representative Stringham for your
patience uh good morning uh members of
the health and human services and
elderly Affairs committee and thank you
for the opportunity to speak with you
today and thank you for the introduction
Mr uh Mr chair uh I am representative
Jerry Stringham representing Lincoln
Wood stock Easton and Livermore and a
member of finance division
3 uh it is an honor to introduce House
Bill
634 titled relative to the New Hampshire
Council on autism spectrum
disorders the purpose of this bill is to
update the mission and membership of the
New Hampshire Council on autism spectrum
disorders so that it can be more
effective in serving the needs of
individuals and families living with
autism across our
state as many of you know autism
spectrum disorder affects a significant
number of individuals in New Hampshire
according to the CDC one in 36 children
in the US are diagnosed with autism and
we know that New Hampshire is no
exception our understanding of autism
spectrum disorder or ASD continues to
evolve and so so too must our support
and
services uh the council was created to
advise state government on policy
services and programs related to a
autism and to be a resource for
individuals and families impacted uh
this Council was created 15 years ago
however as time has passed we realized
that some updates to the council's
mission and membership are necessary to
keep Pace with the growing and diverse
needs of the autism community and its
utility is actually fallen off over the
past 6 years and this bill is an
important step to revive the council and
fulfill its Mission House Bill 634 Pro
uh proposes key updates that will ensure
the council is truly representative of
the various uh varied experiences within
the autism community and that has the
ability to address emerging needs uh
specifically uh this bill Alters the
membership
uh the bill proposes to add members uh
with a broader range of backgrounds but
also simplify the process to fill
vacancies where there are a large number
of them right now uh but further refines
the mission of the council uh basically
it narrowly focuses on enhancing uh
access to services and
information uh and ensure that the
services are inclusive and available
across the state of New Hampshire for
those who need access to
information our state's autism Community
is diverse and complex and as such our
efforts to support those with ASD must
be flexible and responsive uh the
updates proposed in the house bill 634
are aimed at uh ensuring the New
Hampshire Council on autism spectrum
disorders can become more effective in
addressing the needs of individuals with
autism and their family so I urge you uh
to support this uh important bipartisan
bill so that we can ensure that New
Hampshire continues to be a place where
all individuals regardless of their
challenges have the opportunity uh to
thrive uh I would like uh to further
mention that the the um uh contents of
this bill uh were as a recommended by
the council chair uh Vice chair and
secretary and uh so pleased to bring
that forward uh with that I'm happy to
answer any questions that you may have
but U some may be uh answered by others
that are here as well thank
you so based on your last sentence you
may not be the right person to answer so
feel free to pass if if you're not the
right one um we received an email from
somebody who suggests that actually the
right place to address these issues is
in the U developmental servic quality
Council and I wondered if you had any uh
thoughts on whether that was uh a better
place uh a Le less effective place or or
just something that runs in parallel
well I will say you know that I I did
read the the note that came in and the
the author was nice enough to con uh to
copy the sponsors on the bill as well as
the committee and I you know I think uh
that person's
frustration um you know with the with
the count
uh you know effectively not have not
being fully staffed not not producing a
report is shared by the council itself
uh I think that um the fact that the the
members of the council uh are the ones
who are you know put forward putting
forward uh this solution uh or or uh you
know this uh language in order to make
the council more effective as and and
that we're not uh really looking at uh a
delu of effort uh I think it should be
supported so other
questions seeing none thank
you representative redwoods out in the
hall
also signed up to speak is
representative Jess Edwards who is a
co-sponsor of this bill uh thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee I um
uh I'm I'm here essentially to uh just
back up and reinforce uh what the prime
sponsor said um he invited me to work
with him on this bill I've actually put
in very little work uh on this bill but
the the the clinching point the in point
of why I think you should be looking at
this bill is it's it's my understanding
that uh this board this commission has
been having trouble establishing quorums
and because they can't establish quorums
regularly they're not producing they're
not gathering information they're not
producing reports so so whether this is
the right membership and approach to fix
the quum issue um I I you you know
you're you're in a better position for
that um but um if the board can't meet
it can't do its job and I think we want
it to do its job so so that's to me
that's the main reason I'm supporting
this bill let's give this uh committee
an opportunity to to to have their
quorums and to gather the information
and to meet beyond that the fine-tuning
of the membership and how they meet and
what they talk about that's that's uh
levels uh deeper than what I've really
looked at thank you any questions for
representative
Edwards seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Marissa
Berg from the New Hampshire Council on
autism and Spectrum
disorders and I pronounce your last name
correctly okay okay
great you've asked for five minutes
again closer to three would be great if
you can do
it you could turn on your microphone
yeah at about there go there we go um so
uh esteemed chair members of the health
and human services and elderly Affairs
committee my name is Marissa ber I am a
member of the Council on autism spectrum
disorders and this council is uh their
role is outlined in RSA 171a col
32 uh the proposed changes that were
outlined in this legislation were
developed based on feedback that we
received from people with Autism and
their family members and other people
that support them during two feedback
sessions um we had some listening
sessions in November of
2024 um and we really wanted to realign
the purpose of this uh Council to make
sure that it was serving its purpose and
and really supporting people with Autism
in their families so some of those
highlights uh included that individuals
with autism in their families wanted a
greater presence on the council the
council should focus on educating
individuals and families on resources
that were available to them there needed
to be a way for adults with autism to
advocate for their real life concerns
and needs not what people thought they
needed professionals at all
levels and the public need education on
autism and what it's like to experience
the world um with an Autism diagnosis
many people with Autism want jobs and
they want employers who understand the
positive aspects of employing someone
with autism and people who understand
how to best support those
employees and people with Autism should
not be the only ones advocating and
there is a need for in information and
education to be championed by
professionals as well
so the proposed changes to this
legislation include clarifying two
Council appointed seats for people with
Autism adding a dedicated seat for a
family member bringing the total
dedicated to family members to two seats
clarifying that five at large members
will be appointed by the council and
although it's not outlined in the
language before you these were discussed
to be prioritized for people with Autism
or secondarily for family members of
some with somebody with
autism um this also adds a seat for a
new hampshire-based self- advocacy
organization adds a seat for a clinical
service provider who works with people
with
Autism um it also clarifies some roles
so clarifies that the role is to be
aligned with available resources and
build on collaboration with other groups
and
organizations and also clarifying that
they will make Reser recommendations on
best practices for supporting people
with Autism and provide an online
listing of resources for people and
their families and others who support
them in a personal or professional
capacity so we have heard from people
with Autism and their families that
having a dedicated Council would be a
valuable way for them to Advocate and
access resources and that is why we have
uh brought this legislation forth today
and we really appreciate our our
sponsors um for helping us with that and
uh thank you for your time and I'm open
to
questions thank you representative
Weber thank you I I'm just reviewing the
makeup of the council as it is proposed
and I have the concern and
question uh about increasing the size
although I understand the balance is
different of an organization that's
already having trouble meeting its
Quorum and that may be be so my my first
question is is the lack of a quorum
simply because not enough people have
been appointed or because not enough
people have shown up so we have been in
significantly increasing the number of
people who show up one of the things
that has been slowing us down a little
bit is that a lot of those seats are
Governor appointed so um what this does
is this changes the language so that
it's Council appointed um but also
includes a the governor or a design as
as part of that that is one of the
vacant seats right now um so out of
those vacant seats that we don't have to
meet Quorum six of those are for family
members um that require uh some sort of
involvement from um the governor uh to
to be appointed may have a follow follow
thank you that's very helpful um and the
other question I have although I it's a
technique that I often
deplore is have you considered lowering
simply lowering the Quorum requirements
because that happens often with
committees yeah so we do have language
in here uh that aligns with the current
language for uh 91a so I'm not sure how
I mean I'm unfortunately I'm not
familiar enough to know uh how much
outside of 91a we are able to go that we
are simply expecting that um you know we
we do have to follow those guidelines
there is language in here though uh that
allows um for individuals with
disabilities um to count toward a quorum
um because we had seen there was some
precedent for that with the quality
Council to make sure you know many
people with disabilities don't have
access to any sort of Transportation
they can't necessarily Drive um public
transportation is scarce so
so am I correct in thinking that that's
allowing them to participate remotely
and count as part of the Quorum correct
thank you very much that's very helpful
other
questions I'm seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is is Adora
Rodriguez leand from the New Hampshire
Council on developmental disabilities
morning there you go oh yeah when the
red light is on you all set so for the
record my name is isidora Rodriguez
LeAndre I serve as the executive
director at the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities I'm also
currently the interim Vice chair of the
um Council on autism spectrum disorder
and um a Ed member on the New Hampshire
developmental Services quality Council
so I may be able to shed a little bit of
light on how all those are different and
the intent of having a dedicated Council
for individuals and families who
experience Autism Spectrum
Disorder so I have um written testimony
I won't go through and read all of it
but um having heard some of the previous
testimony and some of the questions I I
would like to point out that yes indeed
um this request would allow for
individuals and family members impacted
by disability to count towards in-person
Quorum um for that group we uh in the
last couple of meetings have seen you
know upwards of you know 20 people
participating online but the in-person
Quorum is what's been difficult to meet
and so this would allow for onethird of
the membership to be have to be in
person versus half um and for anyone
online who experiences a disability or
has a family member who experiences a
disability to be counted towards
inperson Quorum if they are
participating remotely um the other
thing that I would like to point out is
that um the New Hampshire developmental
Services quality Council specifically
targets people who are receiving
supports and services in the
developmental services and the Brain
Injury um Services
systems however a lot of folks who are
autistic autistic um have very different
functional and support needs than those
that are provided through the
developmental Services System so a lot
of times people with Autism don't even
qualify for services because they may
not have an intell ual disability or a
functional need that makes them eligible
and so that makes this Council very
unique in that it can help identify the
needs and address the needs of folks who
don't necessarily qualify for paid
Services through our system and that is
a big um difference from all of the
other councils uh that exist
currently um I think the last point I
have is that it's really important to
elevate the voices of those who
experience um disability and autism
specifically um and their family members
to make sure that uh any any uh goals
and objectives and activities are led by
people with Autism and um that is why we
are looking to increase the membership
and we have seen people with lived
experience kind of show up at these
meetings virtually but it is difficult
to get the agency seat if you will in
the
room sure I'm on another commission
myself and I know it was some of the
agencies were very slow in making their
appointments and the statute of this
particular commission said there it's a
14 member commission 8 constitute a
quorum and when you don't have all 14
appointed it can be difficult to get to
that Quorum so yes any
questions not seeing any thank you very
much thank
you okay I have no one else signed up to
testify in HB 634 does anyone else wish
to
testify seeing no one I am going to
close the public hearing on HB
634 and I am going to open the public
hearing on uh HB 73 and recognize the
prime sponsor our representative David
Nagel
thank you Mr chairman um honorable
members of the committee um just
introduce myself um because some of you
don't know me I'm David nigle I'm on
your committee um I'm a physician an
advocate um an author and a legislator
I've worked for 30 years um advocating
for the rights of people with
disabilities including pain um my
primary focus in life has been to
achieve a public policy balance between
the needs of those in pain and those
with addiction and um I would say that
for the most part that's been a total
failure but we can never stop trying um
I also am the uh acting chair of the
opioid abatement commission and I'm the
chair of the State Health assessment and
State Health implementation plan Council
and um this bill that we're talking
about today is very important for both
of those um I'm honored that my two
friends here um representative Edwards
and Senator waters are here um I call
this a quick sand Bill not for the
reason you might think but Senator
Waters proposed this bill last session
and I basically got sucked into it I
didn't sponsor it but the more I heard
about it the more I liked about it the
more important it got the more work we
put into it to give you a little history
and while I'm talking on page three and
four of the bill is a definition of harm
reduction rather than me go over that in
detail I thought you could take a peek
at that but anyways um the reason why
this bill came up was because we're
already doing harm reduction um it's the
one of the pillars of the governor's
commission um the opioid Oatman
commission allows this as a reason for
uh Distributing funds as one of their 19
indic ation so we're already doing it
the problem is unlike other things that
we do there's a little bit of
controversy in it and there was a
feeling that since the term harm
reduction and the concept did not appear
anywhere in statute that it needed to
get there and that and I'm speaking for
the senator but that was pretty much
what led to this the history of the bill
was that um it was brought up in the
Senate it passed in the HHS committee
there five Z was Voice vote in their
finance and and then in the Senate that
then came to us in this committee where
we sent it without a recommendation
initially but on my good friend um
representative kofalt and I sat down
worked on this at length to try to get a
good definition of what harm reduction
meant for us and um with that we were
able to pass the bill um or at least the
amendment that we created um I give you
the numbers um
sorry I don't normally use notes but it
was 249 to
1227 and then it passed the house at 359
to 18 it then went to the finance
commission where my um my friend um
decided that it needed more work and it
went to an her study and you know at
first I was really angry about that
because I put a lot of effort into this
but the more we talked the more it
became apparent that he was right and to
his credit um He suggests that we sit
down over the summer and meet and so
Patrick tus from the governor's
commission U Senator Waters myself and
and representative Edwards sat down
several times over the summer to try to
figure out how to make this workable so
that we could all be at least somewhat
miserable but nobody really miserable
with the outcome and I think this Bild
achieves that
um it's important that you know a little
bit about what harm reduction is and
it's in the bill but there was a
document that was created that tried to
align the strategies of the opioid
abatement commission and the governor's
commission and it basically looked at
all the things that we used do for
substance use disorder and like where
are the gaps how do can we use this
money to really solve problems in our
society help people save lives things
like that and what was interesting when
they came up with it there were huge
gaps in two things number one was
prevention and number two was family
support and so that really raised a lot
of red flags for me as to how this
legislation could make a difference
there um so that's basically where we
came from but prevention has three
elements to it and this is a public
health thing this isn't just an
addiction thing but we differentiate
them between primary secondary and
tertiary primary is where we prevent the
problem from happening in the first
place secondary is early diagnosis or
early assessment and then nip the B nip
the thing in the bud before it happens
example every one of you is in a county
delegation you all have an office of
restorative justice that's what they do
they do secondary prevention tertiary
prevention thoughs a different story the
problem is ingrained it's complicated
and our goal is not necessarily I mean
it would be nice if we can eradicate the
problem but our goal is to prevent the
consequences or minimize the the damage
that the consequences can do and that's
functionally what harm reduction does
it's already in legislation ter AR
prevention is in legislation but the
words harm reduction is not um the bill
itself I think has laudible goals um I
did you want to go over that or do you
want me to go over what's in the bill
now let me do it all right fine all
right good give me more time to talk
here so um the legislation has several
elements to it um the first element is
um is to provide some level of oversight
like for example um we provide Naran for
people we provide um sterile needles we
provide uh sexually transmitted disease
counseling we provide a doorways program
that allows access to other things we do
all that right now and this bill would
allow all those things to continue one
of the controversial issues should we
allow safe Drug Administration sites I
don't know that we're ready for that
that would not allow that to happen the
question is should there or should not
there be financial support and how is
that done that was in the original Bill
we came to the conclusion that that
doesn't is not necessary the funding for
all these programs already exists and we
don't need to provide that um this was
an interesting one that I had never
really thought about but when you're
applying for grants for programs
terminology is really important you know
so if if we're using one language
tertiary prevention and this other group
samsa is using harm reduction then we're
not using the the same language and it
makes aligning our grant requests a lot
more difficult so by using this bill
we're able to actually allow um our
organizations in the state to use the
same language to more effectively
compete um there was an element in the
original bill that allowed for promotion
or education of Health Care Providers it
went way too far only because everything
it it put in there already existed so we
did eliminate that um the doorways
program is really important it's like a
an easy access program it's a hub and
spoke model in the state if you have a
problem 24/7 you can go to one of nine
centers that's the Hub they will then
spoke you out to whoever provides those
services and most of us agree that
that's important it's an important harm
reduction technique um it exists now
like a lot of programs there's a danger
it could not exist so the this bill
allows um that to
continue um let's see what else should
we talk talk about this is the most
important part of what I call our
compromise so I've been working with
people in pain for a long time I've been
working with people with addiction for a
long time I've lived a lot of my life
with people in pain and I've lived a lot
of my life with people with
addiction the problem that I've had with
the whole concept of harm reduction is
that although this is not in the sza
definition before you is that we focus a
lot on the addict and not on the people
around them if you look at the Society
of American society of addiction
medicine's definition of addiction they
say it's basically aberant Behavior
continue despite harm to the self the
old definition said the self and you
those around you and that really
bothered me that they took that out I
think that people with addiction have
are neurophys are victims of their
neurophysiological self but at some
level they're also perpetrators the
things that they do do a lot of harm to
the people around them and what
concerned me about the whole concept of
harm reduction is that it doesn't take
those people into effect for example um
my family had to bury two people with
therosis of liver last in last three
years um from a lifelong history of
alcoholism
um you wouldn't believe how much anger
there is you know what they did to their
families in the process of their
alcoholism and how you wanted to shake
them tell them to stop
whatever and and the family support was
lacking but they had 12 step programs
they could go to they had this that and
the other thing and that's why changing
the way we conceptualize what we were
doing was important so I'm going to give
full credit to um representative Edwards
for coming this up with this but we
changed the term conceptually from harm
reduction to reduction of societal and
individual harm if you go through the
bill um it's actually very simple and
complex at the same time but everything
in Black in the bill is new um but all
this is is the the the statute that
creates the governor's commission um it
changes the words um um harm reduction
which was in the past to including
reduction of society individual harm
every word time the word abuse happens
it um changes that to misuse which was a
real problem for me um
because we don't use that terminology
and pain management and I was really
afraid that we would harm my patients so
there's two places in the bill where we
protect my patients rights to access to
these things um the definition of of
harm reduction at least from a SSA point
of view comes in here with some guard
rails that for example you cannot do a
self Drug Administration site um what
else I think that's pretty much
everything that I have um I did Define
misuse in this I insisted that stay in
there because abuse is really what we're
looking at not misuse for example I
would bet every one of you has misused a
a a prescription drug in your life if
you took a drug that was prescribed to
you for a reason other than it was
prescribed to you you misuse that and
that is the far the most common cause of
misuse how many of you took that coding
that you had from a dentist for your hip
when it your hip hurt or an antibiotic
for a reason that it wasn't so you
you're functionally a criminal um most
the majority of misuse is actually
something that subtle that's not what
we're talking about and that's why it
was important to me that we Define what
we were talking about because the term
misuse is now used in the addiction
circles I think that's everything any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you and Senator Waters welcome I was I
was just about to call you so thank you
Senator David Waters from District 4
thank you very much uh Mr chairman
members of the committee Senator David
Waters District 4 and we're playing tag
team with representative Edwards and he
thought I should come up now I don't
often come into um house hearings on
bills that I'm not the prime sponsor but
I really wanted to be here to to applaud
um representative Edwards and
representative Nagel hear that I should
come up now did you want to join him um
no I just was mentioning you that's all
yeah all right come up whenever you want
um so uh we did put a lot of work in
this bill and I I really want to thank
representative Edwards and particular
for holding U you know holding this bill
so that we come up with a better bill
that had a real consensus as to how to
move forward on a on a difficult issue
I'd like to point out uh briefly just
exactly what the bill um does and why it
was first brought forward a couple of
years ago uh like representative Edwards
I'm a member of the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
and three years ago it started its
strategic planning and decided to create
a new task force on what it was calling
harm reduction and it seemed to me that
if they were going to have that as one
of their four pillars that we ought to
have that in the legislation for the
commission to authorize that and uh then
to provide some definition of it so that
was the original impetus and that's what
we worked on here to get the language um
which I think very wisely represented
Edwards um brought forward to say
including reduction of societal and
individual harm so if you look on um
page two at the bottom you will see that
that has been added to the four main
areas of the governor's commission and
then thus gives the commission authority
to pursue that as one of its main areas
um and as has been mentioned previously
you have a very careful definition of
what we are referring to reduction of
societal and individual harm I think it
is really an effective one that we
notice we're trying to deal with the
folks who have substance uses disorder
but that has impacts on their
communities and municipalities and their
Municipal budget so we have to look at
both together and understand what the
commission and uh what the prevention
programs and recovery programs can do to
make sure that the larger Community uh
is addressed as as well I thought it was
particularly important in this bill to
add the president of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police that
this bill envisions a much stronger
partnership with local police
departments so that they have a say in
how these um
societal uh and individual harm
reduction programs are conducted I think
some municipalities like my Municipality
of Dober has had very good partnership
with recovery organizations um and the
police department and the social worker
in the police department I think some
departments have felt that they have
been a little cut out when it comes to
deciding where and how such programs are
operate so you see in the language a
little bit later in the bill it
specifies that there must be
consultation with local police forces I
think this is an important tool
particularly for Manchester and other um
other cities we are meeting with mayor
Ru on on this bill next week um and I
think that this is will form a much
stronger partnership uh with law
enforcement and and with these recovery
um
efforts um so I won't rehearse again on
page four but I I think that uh this um
essentially identifies a lot of the
activities that there is bipartisan and
Municipal and state consensus on with
HHS of the kinds of activities that are
involved in uh in harm harm reduction um
and uh then I would also you know the
last thing I'll really point to um is on
page uh
8 or the doorways
program um I think that the doorways
program is one of Governor sununu's
great legacies uh he established them by
executive order at a period of
extraordinary crisis with uh opioid um
misuse and and and deaths in the state
we were after West Virginia hardest hit
by the opioid crisis per capita second
highest number of of deaths and Governor
sunu stepped forward we had substantial
grant funding and said we will establish
this this doorway program where in the
communities across the state there is a
one place to go where people can connect
with services and uh I I think you know
I talked with the governor about this
last year and I said you know when we
have executive orders after a few years
when they've proven themselves it's I
think it's very important to have it in
statute so that they statutory Authority
and the doorways program um now as
you'll see described um and this is a
language that I was given through Health
Human Services as a an appropriate way
to define what the doorways program is
and now we'll have it in statute and um
the appropriate legislative involvement
uh there as as well I had pointed to the
um law enforcement issues you'll see on
that same page on page eight down around
uh line 22 I think this is the Crux the
matter um coordinate and collaborate
with other local agencies including law
enforcement agencies and I think that's
just really crucial thing that the bill
uh does as well um so uh with that the
only other comment I'll make is that I
think the drafting attorney just took
the original bill on the effective date
and added two years to it um I don't
know that we necessarily have to wait
until July 1st 2026 um I think would be
awfully good
to get the uh police chief onto the
commission as soon as the bill passes
and to have the other tools for law
enforcement as well as the doorways
program and statute so I mean please do
consider whether we whether it seemed
appropriate to say the usual 60 days
after passage or upon passage instead of
the 2026 so thank you Mr chairman for
your time thank you thank you any
questions repres uh representative Weber
well that last comment kind of bed the
question why was 2020 six put in here to
begin with given that this is an
existing commission that's being
modified rather than something that's
being set up to begin with so why choose
2026 in the drafting process thanks for
the question I I think that what they
did is that they had the bill that you
know the original bill which had the
2024 data on it and I think they just
added two years to it because it was the
older
Bill uh so I I I think that it more
appropriately would be um July 1st 2025
or upon P 60 days after passage but um
maybe representive Edwards have some
comments on I I just wanted specifically
to know whether upon passage or 60 days
after passage what would be your
preference if we have July 1 it's sort
of an
arbitrary yeah I I mean you know who
knows when bills get signed right so I I
think 60 days would be appropriate um
just some time for the okay you know for
the for the agencies to do it they may
need to do other
questions representative
McKay thank you Mr chairman Senator good
to see you uh on it says a
representative of the state's
faith-based
commun faith-based Community who shall
be a nonvoting
member why is why is that in there I
mean it seems very strange
that uh that that's on page
two of line
23 that's the existing
language it's is there any reason why we
shouldn't take that out I mean what why
is he on there if he can't vote I uh
thanks for the question representative
um you know I this this commission was
established a number of years ago in
statute I this is that's the existing
statutary line if the wisdom of this
committee is that they'd like to change
that that's the wisdom of the committee
yeah I used to serve on that
committee any other
questions did you have a clarification
uh representative Nel on that point or
yeah
sorry thank you for the question it was
a good question um faith-based
communities do an awful lot of on the
ground work in addiction management um
and so I think that was probably why
they were included in this because they
are really critical to the work we do in
a lot of different
ways I suppose they might have to recuse
themselves um frequently so but I again
I this is the existing language so I
don't really have an answer to
it representative Woods did you have
your hand
up representative har
haret thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking the question I'm uh very
appreciative of this bill helping you
bring harm reduction into Focus for the
state it's wonderful just had a couple
questions about needle exchange um is
there any evidence that needle exchange
increases intravenous drug use thanks
for the question uh I'm not a scholar on
this but I think HHS can point to
studies that it it uh does not it is I
was here in the legislature um when with
Senator gray and others we passed that
it really is disease prevention it's
about
HIV um it's about he hepatitis it's
about heart disease um and so that's
that's been the main that was that's why
we passed that program and again there's
no change to it here in this bill
followup uh just a a slightly different
subject is there any uh evidence about
whether or not uh syring exchanges
increase or decrease the likelihood of
Engagement and treatment
um thanks for the that question and I I
can actually answer that um personally
because um I have been out to um you
know to I've been out with some of the
recovery organizations um that offer
these services and nashille in
particular I went out to parking lot
behind the library where they go up a
few days a week and and provide the uh
the kits and so on and um to participate
in needo exchange program you have to
have a
card um and what I saw was that these
were people who were known and had
familiarity relationships with the
people delivering the services so there
was a check-in about their health about
recovery they're also Distributing the
lock Zone and so they can have
conversations about what were their
incidents in which that was used and so
um I saw relationships develop there and
I've talked to other recovery
organizations and they say the needle
exchange programs and they offer other
services too because they say line and
uh health health kits of various kinds
to offer to to people and they all they
they tell me that this can this point of
contact and relationship can be
extraordinarily important for getting
people to take the next step to uh enter
recovery programs and treatment so I I I
I I don't know what kind of Statistics
may may be but I can just that one I can
speak for my personal
experience other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so
much also signed up to speak is
representative Jess
Edwards you say your testimony is going
to last six minutes if it could be
shorter that would be wonderful I I I'll
I'll try um there's an they they've said
a lot um but uh I've got some things
that I think are important for the
context of this I'm representative Jess
Edwards uh Rockingham District 31
represent
Auburn Candia Chester and
Deerfield
um now uh I last year um as the chair of
division three I'm the chair again this
year um uh the bill came to me to our
our our committee it had passed the
Senate it had gone to the house it
passed the house policy committee passed
the house with a pretty overwhelming
vote and it came to me and I looked at
it and I had some real issues with it
and so I tugged on Superman's cape a
little bit uh messing with a a senator's
Bill and a bill that this committee had
supported uh but I I thought it needed
to be done and I'll I'll explain to you
you know why that was and that
is um you you need to understand how the
governor's commission operates with its
money uh the legislature has set it up
to where the the the default um funding
for that commission is at 5% of the
alcohol Fund in this coming budget cycle
we think that's going to be about $1
million somewhere in that range um and
uh the the then that money goes to the
commission the commission has I don't
know 40 some people from around the
state stakeholders to uh talk and they
get put on various tasks Force within
the committee and they form a budget uh
and then they vote on the budget they
act as a miniature legislature with
their focus on the the the pillars that
uh the senator had just explained um and
when they come up with uh their budget
and they vote on it that starts the
process of generating contracts the only
check on their decision to spend money
becomes the executive counsel cu the
legislature has delegated the the the
money to them and delegated the decision
authority to them to determine what gets
how the money gets spent and then it's
only the executive Council that serves
as the people's check if if um if
there's a disagreement about the the
social policy and and so that that
concerned me in this particular case
although we had a have had a very nice
history with the commission where they
have U behaved extremely reasonably and
funded good programs and I'm on the
commission so I'm at the risk of
bragging about my participation uh I
didn't screw it up they still kept doing
good work and or we're expected to do
good work but as the bill came in with
the key thing of of having harm
reduction added as an explicit uh new
term of art um uh I got to be concerned
because uh I was paying attention to the
National media and um and what I picked
up was that uh harm reduction was such a
flexible term with no back stop to it
that um you could take pretty much any
issue related to the social determinance
of health and fund it under the title of
harm reduction and so what would that
include that would include education and
access to it it would include economic
stability it would include Health Care
access it would include neighborhood and
built environment it it would include
social and Community context and so you
could go almost anywhere with something
and label it harm reduction and the the
legislature would basically be out of
the loop so significant social policy
could become
uh practice in New Hampshire without the
the representatives of the of the people
really being involved and so am I
fear-mongering well uh if you look at
Portland Seattle Minneapolis and New
York City what you'll see is under the
term harm reduction uh in um I think it
was Portland where U the the homeless
and drug addicted who they were mostly
drug addicted were hanging out in front
of all the retail downtown and the mayor
said this is killing our tax base we
have to relocate these people she was
stopped in doing that because of a
lawsuit that uh said that under the uh
the Oregon law um harm reduction had to
be considered and that by moving the
loiterers out of where they were staying
that that would cause harm and the
government should not be inflicting harm
so this was an issue where where there
was this tradeoff between how do we
protect the health concerns that we have
for uh the addicted and balance it
against the societal needs and
obligations to make sure that we overall
have a healthy environment staying in
front of I think the retail is probably
as good an example as you're going to
find of this tradeoff between taking
care of the individual harm reduction
and making sure that you know we have
the societal interests of tax collection
which funds all of this stuff so so
there needed to be a balance there um in
uh New York City they uh were having
vending machines proposed that would be
free and you could pull out any number
of things to help with harm reduction
one of them were new crack pipes now
that may be a good idea you know but I
think it's a legislative idea I don't
think a group of people appointed to a
board who are delegated the authority to
spend State money money should be able
to uh just go ahead and Implement new uh
um uh serious State uh policy without uh
a check of the legislature and then of
course housing uh keeps coming up as
something you know every attic needs a
place to sleep so so so that's always an
issue and I'm I'm so sorry I I I I I can
wrap it up but I think I do need two
more minutes Mr chair sorry and I'll try
not to your time Qui possible please uh
thank thank you sir okay so even just
this week in New Hampshire let's bring
it home one of uh our our more
well-known representatives in a public
discussion about um Sanctuary status uh
you know made the point that our policy
on Sanctuary status ought to be viewed
as a an aspect of our harm reduction
programs and so this this communicates
the broader point that creating the term
harm reduction is could potentially be
this endless uh possibility of anything
that could be defined under the term and
since we're delegating tremendous money
Authority the idea was let's go ahead
and and have a reasonable boundary
around the kinds of things that we think
are are legitimate harm reduction
policies they' found their way
specifically into the statute um and say
you know go forth and do these things
but if you want to do something outside
this this boundary uh you're going to
need to come and get um legislative
support and that's why you see this uh
ambiguous term many people will think
it's ambiguous where uh there's a a need
to uh balance societal and individual
harm um if you were a systems manager
you would look at this the way systems
manag ERS look at the concept of
subsystem
optimization and subsystem optimization
is if as you're building and designing
organizations and processes and
procedures if you focus on
maximizing the the potential and
capability of one component of the
system you can actually do harm to the
entire system because you've
overemphasized the one component and so
sub system optimization is is a a
warning to systems thinkers that you
have to maintain a balance of the system
and that if you ever see yourself like
overemphasizing uh one component of it
then you're probably doing harm to the
overall system that's two minutes is
almost done yeah yeah um and um and all
of the people that are going to be
involved in this once we let it go um
are are good people with good intent but
in general they have a very specific
focus on the individual and we just want
I think we we we want them to push that
canoe out into the lake understanding
that it's not just the individual they
have to be careful and cautious about um
any impact it may have to the broader
community and Society so uh I could I
could say more this is such a great
topic but I'll shut up any questions for
representative
Edwards I'm saying to say you covered it
so well we have no questions well I
followed uh the experts um both and I
didn't even get a chance to thank them
they were just so great with the
collegiality and they could have been
offended and mad at me but we had some
really great conversations and I think
it's an example of of of of doing
nonpartisan legislation not bipartisan
so thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Chief
suckling from the New Hampshire State
Police I believe it's the New Hampshire
State Police no I'm from the Alexandria
Police Department oh okay
okay please please put your microphone
on there you go is that right yeah I can
hear me yeah you can hear you good
morning uh chairman McDonald and members
of the committee thank you very much for
having me to speak to this bill my name
is Dave suckling I've been a police
officer for 14 years and I've been a
chief of police for uh 12 of those years
I'm currently the chief of police in
alexand at the Alexandria PD and I work
with our Laconia rural community opioid
response Consortium aror for short which
is federally funded program and I
present annually at the National
Conference in DC about police
integration and Community recovery
efforts and I'm also here to support the
New Hampshire Chiefs of Police
Association and I'm proud to say that we
support this Bel um small towns such as
ours are not without our own drug rated
challenges as I'm sure you all know in
2018 I was present in an overdose death
that changed my life and my approach to
policing forever a young man in our
community was late for work and his
parents had gone into his room to make
sure he was awake and instead of awake
they found their son Dead with a bag of
powder beside him he had been a
meaningful recovery for several
years since then Alex Andria PD has
distributed hundreds of doses of Naran
throughout our community and personally
I've taken around 12 people uh to
recovery placements last year and this
is all possible through Community um
Partnerships with recovery agencies and
since then we haven't had a documented
overdose in Alexandria since we started
Distributing n oxone in our town and we
acutely learned that dead people don't
heal which has turned into a bit of a
battle cray and AR fits and lo and
behold what we were doing was harm
reduction we just didn't know what it
was uh we just thought we were saving
people's
lives these efforts haven't been uh in
Lee of law enforcement
efforts and uh we found that people are
often willing to uh explore recovery
efforts uh post arrest while in our
booking room and we've taken several
people to recovery from our booking room
uh for long-term meaningful recovery
which we're insanely proud of of uh
police New Hampshire have a unique
opportunity to talk with people
suffering from substance use disorder
and save lives in the state hence
increasing police legitimacy and more
meaningful interactions with the public
uh and this bill will help bridge the
gap between uh law enforcement and
Recovery agencies uh New Hampshire
Chiefs of police would welcome the
opportunity to be part of the governor's
Commission on the uh alcohol drug abuse
prevention treatment and Recovery
commission and hence we support this
bill I'd like take any questions if you
have any for me thank you any
questions representative kofalt uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so just a point of
clarification I think I heard you say
that you're also in supporting the bill
you are also representing the view of
the New Hampshire Chiefs of police
that's correct okay thank
you other
questions saying none thank you thank
you for having me appreciate you
also signed up to speak is Jenny O
Higgins from the Department of Health
and Human
Services I just realized I didn't know
if it was morning or afternoon I was
gonna say good afternoon but still
morning good morning for the record I'm
Jenny O Higgins I'm the legislative
liaison for Behavioral Health in DHHS
and I'm really here to take any
questions for you all and I um am able
to speak to many of the things that
you've already heard but I won't repeat
that testimony I just wanted to show up
as the department to talk about the
programs that we have in place or take
any of your questions or clarify
anything I before I go to representative
Weber is the department taking a
position on this bill or we're just here
to provide information okay great thank
you representative Weber sorry took care
of my question oh okay sorry it didn't
mean to preemptive
any uh representative plaz
off thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question so uh uh representative Edwards
uh uh gave a scenario when certain um
policy decisions are being
challenged in the court uh on the basis
of definition of h reduction have you
seen anything like
that in New Hampshire
and what are your thoughts on this bill
in regards
to
um uh addressing
situations like that challenges in
court yes so the current um programs
that we are implementing in New
Hampshire in this space really are
within our prevention treatment and
Recovery Support Services we did work
closely with sponsors of the bill and in
the a study committee on harm reduction
to help with um crafting any of this so
I believe that the work that we're doing
today as many others noted is around
saving lives and helping people access
care to protect our communities I don't
think that anything that we have
operating in New Hampshire would is
necessarily Up For Debate or would come
up in in that way follow up uh thank you
for allowing me follow up so reading Z
bill I think uh it's mostly a positive
definitions what hum reduction is but I
don't necessarily see negative
definition what hum reduction is not do
you think we need to include some
negative definitions uh to address like
Society
issues so we don't in the same statute
Define prevention treatment or recovery
which are all the other places sort of
buckets and which we do this work so in
the field in uh I think we have an
understanding of what these definitions
mean and are able to operate based on
the best practices in the field and
we're able to also make um changes
quickly if the on the ground in
collaboration with law enforcement and
Public Safety and our health departments
and Regional public health networks in
order to respond to crises or what's
happening in our environment
and I think part of not needing a
definition for prevention treatment and
Recovery helps us to have that
flexibility and be nimble so overly
defining how we respond especially when
we have major crisis ongoing in the
state could be potentially problematic I
think we can trust the the work of the
governor's commission and those that
they're
funding other
questions seeing none Thank you very
much I have no one else signed up to
testify on h73 does anyone else wish to
testify I'm seeing no one so I'm am
going to close the public hearing on HB
73 our next hearing is going to be on
hb994 FN at 1 pm we'll be in recess
until
then
we do ask other people testifying who
follow to please keep your testimony as
close to three minutes as possible to
allow ample time for questions we have
quite a few people who have signed up to
um speak on this too we want them make
sure everybody gets a fair shot so I'm
sorry to interrupt representative I'll
proceed okay yeah um good afternoon
committee members uh my name is uh
representative Julia soti representing
Rockingham
35 uh Windham and
londondary um this legislation is uh
hb994 it's
uh meant to
uh stop the funding of infant
circumcision it's
bipartisan uh and it's going to be
bipartisan testimony that you'll be here
ing um circumcision is the uh cutting of
the for skin of the penis in other words
uh removing erogenous tissue and
replacing it with scar
tissue uh we seek to U Save the cost on
this and also on the botched
circumcisions uh circumcision is
medically
unnecessary I myself am proof of that as
I am intact along with 90% of the male
population on the
planet uh who have no problems being
intact so far 16 states have passed
similar
legislation the rate of circumcision in
the country is down to
50% other countries that have had
circumcision but got rid of it are
England and Canada when they went to a
socialized medicine
system uh in Canada another contrib in
Factor may have been that a child lost
his penis to a botched circumcision very
tragic uh person was raised as as a uh
girl and then later committed
suicide now I would like to draw a
distinction between uh religious
circumcision and secular circumcision
and how it's related to harm I'm going
to quote from a rabbi rabbis perform
circumcision from a documentary uh
called cut slice slicing through the
midst of circumcision it's a rabbi uh
Hershey warsh he's brutally honest here
he says it's painful it's abusive it's
traumatic and if anyone not in the
Covenant does it I think they should be
put in
prison I don't think anybody has an
excuse for mutilating a child now we
have to draw the
religious uh ethics here it's in the
Covenant versus the secular ethics which
is what we're supposed to be doing we're
in a secular secular category now how
did circumcision become a secular thing
I handed that the history out but in a
nutshell um during the late
1800s when medicine was more snake oil
and less
science there there are
puritanical uh prudish quacks promoting
circumcision and they outright uh say it
it's to diminish sexual
pleasure it cures
nothing even though there are many
claims that it
does uh it's a cure in search of a
disease and it's backwards that's
backwards science there's a lot of bogus
funding uh generally by people who have
been circumcised and want to get the
results that they want to get because
they're funding the the studies and I
find it very strange um people are
missing a body part extoling the virtues
of missing that body part and you know I
ask them about and they say oh I know
what I'm missing I think how no you
can't you don't have that
part you can't feel what you don't have
that is epistemologically impossible
you've never felt the natural normal
function of your penis you have no
standing on the issue no pun
intended it's it's like the colorblind
person touting the merits of being
Colorblind on and by the way um also in
the with regards to female circumcision
it's the same thing there are women who
have been had female circumcision
performed on them in some societies and
they want to do it to their
girls they have no standing there too
total color blindness on the
issue well so so to
conclude I would ask the people who are
promoting circumcision tell me again why
I should have had highly innervated
aerogenous tissue cut off of my body or
my children's
body for Medicaid to pay for
circumcision is an immoral harmful
taking theft of the child's bodily
autonomy and I think with
that I'll finish up oh one other thing
last time when I put in some testimony I
quoted from various people who had been
harmed from circumcision some of them
were celebrities and I found it quite
offensive how the other side mockingly
referred to them it's very offensive to
mockingly refer to people who have been
harmed by circumcision just because some
of them were
Comedians and with that if anybody has
any questions I have I guess I've become
a expert on this
topic
um thank you yeah any
questions I'm oh representative Woods uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um was there any
reason your microphone a little closer
representative Woods I'm having a little
heing thank you um was there any
particular reason I mean I can imagine a
few but why did you focus just on
Medicaid well
um one of one of the ways to save I
guess save the money and also on B
circumcisions
um the issue as far as on the religious
side that's something that they have to
within their
Community um like Jewish folks have also
moved to something that's called Brit
Shalom where they don't do cutting so
um basically this is where we need to
start with public awareness by cutting
it at at the Medicaid
level other
questions representative
palazov thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh does the State
Medicaid plan covers female circumcision
uh no in fact there's a law that bans
you can't even take a pin prick to
anything on a woman oh that reminds me I
have some other things here there is a
testimony that you guys got but I
printed it out from an attorney uh Eric
Clopper uh he's going to be uh suing all
the states for equal protection so I'll
hand this out too um he and he's going
to be coming around to New Hampshire too
maybe we could preemptively do something
about this but
anyway other questions representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question um there was a
statement somewhere that the state would
save something like $100,000 I think
that was a FIS note or something yeah I
believe is breakdown for that where that
comes from it's hard to break it down
but uh the um we got it from Department
of Revenue I believe um and there's also
extra numbers that and and I can send it
out to you in an email uh where it the
Box circumcisions cost just as much as
the initial cost maybe even more to do
the
repairs but uh I'll have to get those
numbers to you and and the re if I can
clarify sorry yeah fell the reason why I
bring it up is I I'm sure there's an
administrative cost and then a a
reimbursement cost but I mean all the
providers that I know that do this say
they don't make much money doing it you
know it's like 20 30 bucks tops you know
so that's why I was struck that the
number was so big well the fact that it
exists in that chap that administrators
and everybody all bureaucrats to dealing
with it cost money if you just like
strike it
from the process you're going to
save no matter
what other
questions saying none okay thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is
representative Jonah
wheeler Hillsboro
33 thank you Mr chair friends and
colleagues on the house Health and Human
Services committee my name is
representative Jonah oan wheeler I
represent the towns of petero and Sharon
I'm here today just to quickly say that
I don't support
State sanctioned circumcision plain and
simple uh it really isn't about cost
savings although it's always good to
save money where we can for me it's
about this is an elective procedure that
is
uh I don't think as beneficial as is
purported by supporters of circumcision
and it is elective and Medicaid services
shouldn't in my opinion cover such
elective procedures so I'm happy to take
any questions but that's really all I'm
here to say I yeah thank you Mr chairman
thank you any questions representative
Woods thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question absolutely I just
need two questions clarification you
said it's elective and therefore
shouldn't be covered I that's kind of a
confusing statement could you clarify
that well you would know better than I
as a doctor I
I don't believe that uh circumcision
should be covered by Medicaid maybe
that's what I should have said instead
of the word elective I mean I have a
total hip which is an elective
procedure but that was
covered like I just said I'll change
what I said to circumcision shouldn't be
covered to Medicaid follow follow up um
in medicine we try and emphasize the
relationship between the phys phys and
the
patient um to what extent should that be
considered in in this
venue I think that the Medicaid services
here you know we're not Banning
circumcision just means that it's not
funded by the state and uh if the doctor
and the patient want to have a
conversation about cutting the tip of
the penis off of their newborn baby then
they're absolutely able to have that
conversation but to me the procedure
should be a lot more researched studied
by those parents and with informed
consent proper informed consent I don't
think a parent regardless of or uh
irrespective of their religious re views
would would elect to have this procedure
done to their
child other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
also signed up to speak is
representative Paige
boschman you'd ask for five minutes
again if you could keep it to three i'
appreciate it I was overshooting in case
okay over Pro under promise and overd
deliver uh thank you everybody here on
the committee for having me here today
my name is Paige Bosman I am a
representative from Hillsboro 3 I
represent NASA's Ward 4 I am oh let me
get my
notes I am also a registered nurse and I
am certified in maternal mental health
from the only certifying board in this
country um I have been working for 15
years in both Maternal Child Health as
well as Health Equity and uh mental
health within the uh maternal
space I um as of even just six months
ago I was the nurse who talks to the
patients about the education around this
and I'm the one that would assist the
physicians in the circumcisions and I I
did uh I did speak to this last year um
I am here because as written or excuse
me I I am uh opposed to this bill for
some very specific reason so I would
like to just kind of put out there um
you may hear testimony
uh to to the opposite of this but
circumcision is well um uh it is well
accepted that it is not medically
necessary so we we should start from
that position the American Academy of
Pediatricians for many years now maybe 5
to 10 um have said that it is not
medically necessary now I have been an
educator for 15 I teach newborn care I
have been teaching parents that for 15
years I am uh in agreement with most of
the anti-circumcision information that
you will hear today um and I agree that
we should significantly decrease that I
do believe it is a body autonomy issue
with that being said I do not believe
that de that taking away Medicaid
funding is the right way that we do that
representative Woods as you said we in
medicine prefer to work with our
patients and meet them where they are
nationally the rate of circumcision
right now is about uh in the 60% while
in New Hampshire it's
76% most parents do not know that it's
not medically necessary given that
circumcision has very deep cultural and
religious um Foundation right people
have very deep belief systems about that
I very much worry about just taking that
away from them um by making it
unavailable only to our lower income
constituents um if circumcision is is
everything and as terrible as we say it
is I believe we should be banning it
outright if we're not convinced that
it's egregious enough to ban it outright
then why do we think that it's okay to
take it away in a discriminatory way
just from a certain group of people my
recommendation would be that we work on
education although I'll tell you that in
Maternal Child Health there's a lot of
Education that doesn't get to the
parents and we are working on that I
work every day on that my final sentence
I would recommend that instead of
banning this that we find a way to
improve the education in the state and
then in a few years look at legislating
how we might decrease it if we need to
at that point thank you very much thank
you any questions representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question I always struggle with this
whole concept of medical necessity and
electivity sure um I mean one of the
reasons I think this bill is being
pursued by some is to cut costs um and
and and moving on from that when they
tell me if I'm wrong but when they
studied this in Florida and they removed
the Medicaid reimbursement the the the
cost of the system actually Rose because
of the increased number of post neonatal
or newborn circumcisions they had to do
is that your experience or you know that
actually brings up a really really
really good point um I I'm not familiar
with that what I can tell you you is
that when people are not getting the
appropriate education on how to care for
an uncircumcised penis then we do see
rates of infection go up so that's
another reason that I think education is
so important if we're just Banning it
without providing the education we may
or may not be actually improving
outcomes or decreasing costs I do want
to add that um I was looking at the bill
and I saw in the fiscal note that that
it was indetermined and that it was
either 100 100,000 increase or decrease
in cost so we actually don't know that
in the next few years this would
decrease cost it could actually increase
it by $100,000 according to the note
thank you I would also like to say that
the um online opposition to this out of
about as of a few minutes ago about 150
of the 172 in opposition are from out of
state thank you did you have a follow-up
representative um you all said yeah I
guess I do have another one so um do you
mind no no all right so the the chief
reason medical reason given for
circumcision is um to prevent or
minimize the risk of sexually
transmitted disease later in life um in
countries where those are endemic uh
especially AIDS it is actually
recommended for medical reasons that it
be done in the United States is are
these STDs particularly AIDS considered
endemic enough for us to consider
consider this as more than elective or
not me medically there is no reason to
get this there is it does not decrease
overall just having the circumcision
does is not what decreases the infection
um it it's education or excuse me um
it's not the circumcision that will
decrease it we can combat that by doing
proper education and teaching people how
to keep a clean penis and how to have
safe sex so a circumcision we don't cut
off pieces of people's body for other
reasons preventatively right we don't we
don't we don't remove everyone's breasts
because they might get breast cancer
someday some we do right but not but not
across the board right we do it when
there's a medical necessity for it not
as a preventative
measure uh representative paza and then
representative Woods thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question if
you can help me with uh
terminology so between not medically
necessary and elective do I understand
correctly that not medically necessary
is a sub group of uh larger group of el
elective procedures and that elective
means uh not urgent but nonmedically
necessary is like means there's no no
medical benefit I might even refer to
some of the dogs here I'm not sure that
there is an official definition or where
that definition would come from I think
commonly they're used interchangeably
but I could be incorrect there um what I
can tell you is if something is
medically my take on it if something is
medically unnecessary then choosing it
would be elective but I could be
corrected representative Woods I'll set
okay anyone else any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very much for this opportunity I
appreciate it
also signed up to speak is
representative Jess
Edwards and if you could hold it to
about three minutes
representative that should do it uh
representative Jess Edwards uh i' I've
introduced myself today uh so I'll I'll
dive into it um so part of the homework
that I've been engaged in with division
3 which is the DHHS
resource committee budget committee uh
finance committee um has been to be
taking a look at the agency budget and
looking for ways in which we might
reduce it um and uh as we're going
through there I asked the question what
would happen if we were to uh say that
Medicaid uh should not be paying for and
I use the phrase elective surgery and
and I think Dr Woods has made me think
well maybe the real word I'm looking for
is cosmetic surgery you know some
category uh where um a certain type of
procedure uh isn't banned I don't think
we should be in the business of banning
but as the stewards of the State dollars
we should definitely be in the business
of determining what's an appropriate
reasonable um element of care for uh a
Medicaid recipient and uh and I I think
rather than I don't like this shot or
this sniper approach of going in and
picking a procedure do this procedure by
procedure I think that's an
inappropriate legislative action um and
I developed that with
the around representative uh Weber long
ago when we were dealing with uh uh
medical cannabis and we were nicklin and
Diamond uh diagnoses over and over and I
just thought this is not the way the
legislature should be engaging the
medical field so so from that I I
develop the Fe feeling that we should be
talking about types of care not specific
elements of care and if we were to say
something like you know Medicaid shall
not reimburse for uh cosmetic or
whatever I'll I'll let I'll defer to the
medical people on what the right word is
I think we would also capture in that um
the female version which is a
clitorectomy uh which is probably
something that uh Medicaid dollars also
should not be paying for so instead of
doing these one bill at a time kinds of
things I I think it would be much better
if we just stayed at a conceptual level
and left the medical profession to
interact with their patients we're not
in the business of banning we are in the
business of deciding how to use scarce
Healthcare dollar so with that I'll take
questions thank you hi representative
Weber thank you and thank you for taking
my question
um and I understand your um schematic
for how to deal with these and in many
ways I I agree with it because I think
otherwise you
get the question of what's equivalent to
what else I think you're going to get
that if you try to Define also but my
question is if you're looking at a
strict cost issue yeah um I know that
representative bman used in her te
referred in her testimony that need to
educate parents about the proper care of
the foreskin and I am aware anecdotally
of a family where three boys had to have
circumcision procedures later in their
childhood because that those procedures
have not been followed so um do you have
any knowledge or opinion about what
whether we might be saving
on initial care but incurring more in
after care if we neglect the educational
piece that comes with it in either case
yeah so thank you for the question and I
I have to disclaim my background
although I've been working in healthc
care from a managerial role for over 40
50 years now uh I don't pretend and uh
have any diagnostic knowledge uh that's
that's worth a Committee hearing um to
the question though of of of of finances
and the DHHS organization I'd say that
they do have a component of Public
Health and that we have experts and
professionals who worry about you know
uh what kind of Public Health is
necessary to maintain a healthy
Community we have a public health force
that takes look at Health Equity issues
to take a look to see if we have any
cultures uh or
demographics uh who specifically need to
be some intervention knowledge
intervention so that they can equally
access the Health Care system so so so I
know that we have a distinct public
health education area and I would not be
bringing you know circumcision into that
or yes or no I would just say let's
let's set up the systems and let the
professionals run with it with our
expertise or with our our general uh
consent and and resourcing to the issue
of dollars when I'm talking to my LBA I
said so how much might we save he said
it's probably 50,000 maybe 100,000 a
year now he's not a doctor either so we
didn't say okay well if you avoid this
procedure you may incur this other
procedure we didn't we didn't do the
health economics we were just looking at
you know how much General funds might we
save if we if we uh put a restriction
into the Medicaid
Eligibility other
questions yes representative
Lamonte thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question some people may
look at
circumcision and the choice to make that
um for a family with their doctor as a
parental rights issue do you think by
passing this legislation we might be
saying people on Medicaid have less
choice in their parent to exercise their
parental rights than than people have
private
insurance I thank you for the question I
I I I haven't thought through it so I'm
I'm going to Freewheel it a little bit
it feels to me like maybe you're you're
conflating a couple of very important
things that don't necessarily need to be
appended to one another there's a
there's a parent certainly there's a
parental rights thing and and and and I
would address that more from the angle
of you know let's not ban the procedure
you know if if if it's appropriate to
educate them around it let's I'm okay
with that too um but I I would I would
keep that distinct from the obligations
of the state to pay for a service and
the money that we spend through the
Medicaid Program in my belief uh we
ought to be focusing on taking scarce
resources and applying them to where
they are of most use and so I would
avoid anything that was kind of cosmetic
in in nature and uh I could get myself
in trouble with that even because if
after a a breast
removal a patient may want some sort of
surgical um rebuild reconstruction and
you know I don't know from a
psychological perspective if that would
be the right way to go I I'm not a I'm
not a healthcare provider I'm a i
resource healthc care and I'd rather
just give them U Concepts and principles
and and that should be in the law not
the eaches not the
details other questions representative n
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question you just kind of raised an
issue for me about this particular bill
and I wanted your opinion on this yes
sir so um it lists all the indications
for which you can do a circumcision and
letter k on page who says for any
diagnosed condition for which a
circumcision is deemed medically
necessary by a Health Physician or
healthc care provider license in New
Hampshire I think you know me well
enough that I practice what we call
biopsychosocial medicine where I look at
the entire person and and so there's
biological psychological social
diagnosis it seems to me that this line
pretty much nullifies the whole effect
of the entire bill because I can be
incredibly creative in coming up with a
medical reason to justify why I'm doing
from that perspective is that a problem
with this bill do you think I you I I
have a the my problem comes in a more
strategic level so I haven't walked
around in the in the muck where you're
at uh I I I don't like just overtly
picking out a medical procedure and and
giving a thumbs up or thumbs down on a
procedure I think uh it's up to us to
come up with what the right uh concept
is to hand over to the Health Care
Professionals and the people who
reimburse for these services and and
basically stay out of um politicizing a
particular medical
procedure other questions representative
delus thank you Mr
chairman so representative do you think
that this should be
amended uh it the the it belongs to the
committee now if I were on your
committee I would have a real problem
with this without a significant
Amendment because I think uh while well-
intended it I I it feels to me like it's
a a a horsedrawn wagon going down the
wrong trail
fast other question representative
hartnet thank you Mr chair uh thanks for
taking the question this is a little bit
off point but are you suggesting that we
should uh in effect with Medicaid create
a list of prioritized conditions
that we would move up or down on uh
based on
resources that's an interesting concept
Oregon has done that you know where
they're Medicaid they've got you know
1,500 procedures racked and stacked and
if you start running out of money you
line it out at the bottom um that's that
would require a very mature uh
organizational structure at DHHS that we
don't have today so I wouldn't propose
that as a as a solution and so I'm
looking for um kind of maybe a more
sophomoric approach to keep it
simple follow up yeah just but you like
the
concept the concept of how uh organ
Medicaid does it on a rack basis I I I
actually don't because what they've done
is they've gone in and they've
determined through whatever process they
have of which procedure is more valuable
than another and that is the business of
health eth ethicists and economists and
it's it's a very complicated process and
I don't know that that's where we want
government at that level of
detail where we would basically be um
putting our own uh Financial protocols
in place of a healthy patient um
provider
experience thank you other
[Music]
questions seeing none thank you uh thank
you for your time marel thank you for
taking thank you for taking my call uh
my question uh so can you give me a
working definition of what medically
necessary
is I I I I am not qualified to answer
your question if we were sitting around
having a beer talking about it i' I'd
throw about some ideas at you that I
wouldn't ever want to be held
accountable for I I would just ass soon
come to a committee that's with has
nurses and Physicians and PAs and say
hey here as a finance guy here's what
I'm thinking would you please take this
to the next level of maturity let's
figure out how to get this concept in
place with the right terminology so that
we can delegate to uh the Professionals
in the field you know our expectation
what needs to be the circumstance under
which they get
reimbursed thank
you other
questions okay I think we're safe this
time thank I really meant three minutes
so I I apologize no that's
fine also signed up to speak is Adrien
sodi
and ma'am you asked for five minutes if
you could keep it closer to three I'd
appreciate
it all right can you hear me all right
we
can brought again okay so my name is
Adrian soti I live in Windham New
Hampshire
and I'm here to support this bill to
stop state coverage of circumcision my
husband is sponsoring this bill and
together we have raised two sons and a
daughter none of whom are circumcised
despite having been born in this
circumcising country where this
procedure is readily solicited to
unassuming parents as if it was Alle leg
legitimate choice to
make I am here to tell you circumcision
is not a sound medical Choice Physicians
from other parts of the western world
including Europe Canada and Australia
where circumcision is no longer covered
have formally critiqued the American
Academy of Pediatrics in the Journal of
Pediatrics seen from the outside
cultural bias reflecting the normality
of non- therapeutic male circumcision in
the United States seems
obvious American parents are sold a lie
and the state of New Hampshire should
not pay for it parents assume they are
doing a favor to their sons but doctors
do not share with them information at
all on the benefits of keeping their
sons intact if your boys were born in
most any other part of the
world they would be no more likely to be
circumcised than your girls if medical
quacks in the Victorian era had not
popularized this procedure to prevent
all imagined ills from
masturbation and modern doctors in this
country wouldn't have duped you into
believing that it's healthier you would
have never considered
it your protective instincts would have
kicked in like ours did and you would
not have allowed an authority figure to
get anywhere near your precious baby's
genitals where they could leave an
irreversible mark on
it why are doctors subjecting innocent
infants to such torturous genital
reducing surgeries when they are
powerless to
resist why would we cut off parts of our
bodies for Hygiene when we could just
wash them instead why would you trash
erogenous tissue when you can just
practice safe sex to prevent
diseases if I came to you with a scalpel
and demanded you give up an erogenous
tissue from anywhere in your body you
would think I was crazy yet this is
exactly what is done to boys every
single day in America boys deserve
respect just like our girls do it's not
their body that needs to be cut but the
funds that our state contributes to
perpetuating a misguided practice whose
time has come to
end Moes do not get reimbursed by any
health insurance for performing
religious circumcision on the eighth day
of life which is when their procedure
must be done performing this surgery in
the hospital doesn't satisfy the
religious
Covenant Muslims also do not typically
have their circumcision ceremonies at
Birth but when the boy is nearing
puberty thank you very much and if you
have any questions thank you thank you
any
questions don't see any thank you very
much thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Ellen Reed from
Rockingham County District
10 thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members I wasn't sure if I was
going to testify or not so I've I've
just written down some of the questions
I've heard just for introduction my name
is Ellen Reed I um serve Rockingham 10
that is New Market and newfields I was a
CO sponsor of both bills last term spoke
on both bills in committee spoke on them
on the floor as well um for disclosure I
am a staunch proponent of a single-payer
Health Care system I believe Healthcare
is a human right one of the arguments
I've heard about this particular bill is
that it might be an attack on Medicaid
so I'm going to try to go through some
of the questions I heard and um I'm I'm
Distributing an amendment which I will
explain shortly and I hope the chair
will allow me time to do that um so
I think when we talk about a lot of
issues like this that we've kind of
adopted in our society we have an
emotional reaction because we have a an
investment in in our knowledge of what
the world is what is okay and acceptable
what we're used to and so there's often
a very emotional reaction but the thing
is is that if you look at the facts
neonatal non-medically
necessary um circumcision is mutilation
it's mutilation of a child's body part
against that child's will I know we've
had the question of Parental Choice come
up come up but you can talk about
parental choice and I don't think I
think in terms of cosmetic procedures
it's across the board people without
funds don't have as much Choice as
people with with funds have when it
comes to cosmetic procedures which this
is um but it's not really about parental
choice because that's a child's body
that child will become an 18-year-old
one day and that that choice was taken
away from
them I don't
frequently get to say that I agreed with
much of what representative Edwards said
but I did agree with a lot um he brought
up female genital mutilation I wanted to
correct the record female genital
mutilation which comes in many forms
some of which are far more severe a
clitorectomy is more severe than a male
circumcision um but the most common is
the REM removal of the clitoral hood
which is exactly analogous to
circumcision and that's illegal forget
Medicaid that's illegal federally it's
legal in the state it's illegal I'm
pretty sure in all 50 states in addition
to Federal because it's
mutilation um the question was brought
about the cost versus um save analysis
um so the the numbers are um about uh
one in six depending on how you define a
complication one in six to 1 in 20
neonatal circumcisions result in a
complication the prime sponsor last year
had a very compelling story that she
said to this committee about what
happened with her son that ranges from
anywhere when you're talking about one
in six to like excessive bleeding um and
excessive pain to um lifelong disability
and in some cases death in fact over and
this is not New Hampshire it's across
the country but 100 baby boys die from
results of complications of neonatal
circumcision a year the save analysis of
that is if you don't do that how many of
them need circumcision later in life
that answer is one in
16,000 80% of the world is not
circumcised animals are not circumcised
horses dogs cats they all have
forkin complications in their lives from
infections for having foreskin very very
rare so you can save all of those circum
Neal circumcisions and then one in
16,000 may need an adult I do think I
know who the representative is referring
to about that Family who was a genetic
predisposition but that particular
person please um was in favor of the
bill last year um so let me skip over
some of these other things and get to
the amendment that I distributed because
I don't want this seen as an attack on
Medicaid uh even though the the amount
is very minor about $100,000 but I have
a procedural question Mr Mr chairman
representative Weber sure um the
amendment as far as I can see uh relates
entirely to the children's vision
screening it's a non- ger and how is it
it's a non-g gerine Amendment so isn't
my understanding we cannot hear it now
you're not hearing it I'm explaining
what I think is a solution to one of the
main arguments of the bill before you if
the argument to the bill before you is
that it's an attack on Medicaid then the
solution is to take those funds and
reallocate it to another service this
particular service is a service that was
uh very seriously considered by this
committee over the last two years which
is the idea of a vision screening
program you retained that bill you did
an interim study on that bill and then a
large percentage of this committee was
still in favor of that program my
understanding is that program costs very
little similar to the circumcision so
it's a kind of a one for one you take
away this coverage and you give that
coverage you're not attacking Medicaid
we're still covering children but in
this case we're covering actual medical
needs instead of covering the only
cosmetic procedure non-reconstructive
procedure paid for by taxpayer funds we
are no longer covering mutilating
children and I guess take
questions any questions for
representative Reed yes representative
palazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking uh my question uh
so um in terms of uh medical necessary
procedures uh is it true that one of the
need for newborns to get vitamin K shot
is to help with bleeding after the
circumcision and so is it true that if
we um diminish cases of circumcision
there will be less need and expenses for
vitamin K shots um thank you for the
question I am under the understanding
vitamin K shots are not very expensive
but I believe you that that is a a
treatment and that does apply um to uh
babies who just had part of their body
removed for no reason um I will say that
I do we brought up the term medically
necessary I think that's an actual good
thing because it's determined by the
doctor and I don't know how saying that
it's up to the doctor whether or not
it's medically necessary I don't know
how that's being a bad thing it's I
think it's a very good thing that the
doctor is the one determining whether
it's medically
necessary other
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Lui
Evans and again ma'am you've asked for
five minutes if you could keep it to
three I'd appreciate
it hello thank you for this opportunity
dear esteem committee members I urge you
to support this bill for 40 years I have
been educating health professionals and
parents on the functions of the four
forkin what is lost when a boy is cired
and forkin care why in the mid 80s
before becoming a mother I was teaching
parents to massage their babies and
training professionals to do this work
to promote my work I exhibited at a
health fair where Dr Robert Mendelson
was speaking an orthodox pediatrician
from the University of Chicago he is one
of the few doctors who spoke of the
medical myths of circumcision
in his book he wrote quote if your
doctor suggests circumcision for your
baby boy ask him why he wants to expose
the poor kid to the pain the possibility
of infections or Hemorrhage and the risk
of death from surgery that has no
medical justification unquote I found
this info disturbing no one in my family
wanted to discuss this being Jewish and
obedient I was torn
my work was to ensure nurturing peaceful
Beginnings for newborns so I could not
ignore it I needed to research more once
pregnant my maternal Instinct empowered
me most people do not realize that the
foreskin protects the glands like the
eyelid protects the eyeball if the
eyelid were removed the eye would no
longer be moist and there would be no
moving part I learned that the foreskin
is attached to to the glands like the
nail to the nail bed and before it is
removed it must be
detached four Skins are used to make
derap patch for burn victims and added
to cosmetic creams though neither the
infant nor his parents get money for
this last year while watching the video
from this legislative body I heard a man
speak about being cired as an adult most
of these cirks are unnecessary I
recently learned of a 79-year-old intact
man who had a persistent rash and was
scheduled for circumcision we informed
him to to apply liquid acidophilus the
rash disappeared and the surgery was
cancelled a couple told me a doctor
recommended a circumcision for their
adolescent son because his foreskin
wasn't retracting some boys do not
retract until puberty this is normal no
medical profession should be attempting
to retract the the boy
and they did not allow the circumcision
after getting information from me as the
founder of Noir New York Hudson Valley
and co- director for 19 years I often
exhibited at large baby fairs where I
heard many stories mothers who told me
their son's circumcision having not been
given information beforehand was their
worst nightmare one mother told me her
2-year-old was in pain every day how can
I help to end this needless pain and
suffering although the bill is not about
circumcision for religious reasons it is
important to share that I am a Jewish
mother with an intact son I live by
first Do no harm I tell people my son's
religion is in his heart his soul and
not in his genitals by his deeds and his
relationships I have searched for a
group that supports Jewish life without
circumcising I please one more minute
I've got to finish this I'm a member of
bruhe who supports Brit Shalom a
covenant of peace and Spares the child
the
circumcision due to my work I have heard
men negatively impacted by this in
November
20124 in New York I saw the guy who got
cut wrong the true story of Gary
steinhart's botch circumcision he also
wrote an article in the New Yorker due
to the C during the Q&A he shared that
men have contacted him to vent their
botch circumcision stories and the pain
lifelong pain and suffering it has
caused some speakers will argue that not
allowing Medicaid coverage deprives
low-income family in reality it spares
more inference from suffering and a
lifetime of reduced sexual function I
just want to say too as a long-term
Advocate sometimes we do bills I would
like to have seen last year's bill bill
passed on informing parents beforehand
but that didn't pass and so we're here
to do something I say let's get this
bill passed so that less boys and the
men they become suffer thank you thank
you any questions yes representative
palazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so you said that
some boys do not retract until puberty
is it your position that even if they do
not retract it's still easier to to wash
the pot and keep it uh clean and healthy
the forest skin protects the glands and
so there a lot of doctors tell parents
to retract it to wash but we just say
clean what is seen so there's no problem
in keeping clean and there is a minor
procedure to be done if as an adult the
man is still not retracting but it does
not involve circumcision
other
questions you okay go ahead
representative n Mr chairman thanks for
taking my questions you you seem to have
some expertise about the history of this
why did people ever start doing this in
the first place do you know I think that
um representative soti gave out a a
handout that I shared with him this was
in the
medical um journals I read them again
few nights ago and I was quivering it
said that in order to reduce
masturbation to inflict pain it
specifically says this throughout the
years the goal was to inflict pain to do
the procedure without anesthesia because
what happens when a boy is retracting he
he will begin to do that himself that's
a natural occurrence like someone else
said every male mammal has a force skin
and there's nothing wrong with that so
um but during the Victorian era they
thought that masturbation caused
epilepsy hair on your palms and we
actually had a woman because every four
years we had an event with doctors
lawyers men who were botched everybody
gets together we have medical textbooks
and um I lost my train of thought oh a
woman until I think it was the 70s I'd
have to verify the year she was caught
masturbating by her parents and taken to
be circumcised this was done to women
back then they wanted to inflict
pain thank you any other questions
representative TZ
oh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um thank you you
uh have a lot of uh perspective on this
and it sounds like you might have
knowledge at a national level have there
been efforts um to influence the AAP the
American Academy pet itions or insurers
like not just Medicaid in New Hampshire
but just insurers in general because it
seems like that would be if if it if the
goal is to have it essentially banned
except for you know exceptional
circumstances it seems like that would
be the place to be making the efforts
thank you for that question we have
tried nationally to get um equal and
because now that it's ban for women to
get um equal legislation on that issue
we used to have booths because we have a
group doctors opposing circumcision and
the National Organization circumcision
information Resource Centers um that has
now merged with intact America but they
used to have booths at the American
Academy of pediatrics at the American
Medical Student Association events
interestingly and I was shocked by this
the obies the Obstetricians do I believe
maybe someone can verify that do they
were doing at least half of the
circumcisions why why they do that on a
boy and they would not let us have an
exhibit at their events so we would
stand outside and I still remember we
were there our the signs one of the
signs said must this be a boy's first
sexual experience and to the doctors do
your hands harm or heal but a Jewish
doctor walked by and screamed at us it's
in the Old Testament and um and it's my
religion and the man next to me said I
was circumcised by a Jewish doctor in a
Catholic Hospital and I'm neither of
those religions and I feel as a Jewish
woman one of the things I can say is the
the committee at the AAP the
Pediatric um organization they're often
Jewish people and so I'm very grateful
to bruhe because bruhe is trying to get
it used to be we were under the radar Dr
Ron Goldman in Massachusetts has a list
of thousands of Jewish couples who did
not circumcise Sons but we didn't want
to tell anyone because we would often
feel that we wouldn't be accepted in our
communities and so now we have an
organization that is working to get us
accepted that we are still I was not
looking for Jews who had abandoned the
religion I wanted to be my religion but
I didn't want to harm my son hope that
answers some of the questions other
questions yeah I'm seeing none thank you
ma'am thank you
also signed up to speak is Joseph Harter
from the medical
community good afternoon uh Mr
chairperson and members of the committee
my name is uh Dr Joseph Harter and I'm a
general surgery resident physician I'm
here today to speak in support of this
bill every physician who performs a
surgery has sworn to uphold the
hypocritic oath which emphasizes first
Do no harm and to avoid overtreatment
the non- therapeutic circumcision of
minors fundamentally contradicts these
principles the surgery is typically
performed within infant's first days of
life and it's during this vulnerable
period that the majority of parents have
their initial discussion with a
physician about circumcision and parents
often face undue solicitation to pursue
the surgery particularly those who chose
to keep their child intact
consequentially the decision is largely
based on cosmetic preferences rather
than an informed evaluation of the
Practical risk and benefits of the
surgery now one of the greatest
responsibilities of a surgeon is knowing
when not to operate as every surgery
inevitably causes harm this judgment
requires a thorough understanding of the
condition being addressed to avoid
overtreatment and deliver level
appropriate care in a case of non-
therapeutic circumcision there is no
pathology being addressed this bill
excels at avoiding harmful overt
treatment and highlighting medically
indicated reasons for circumcision when
these practices are upheld studies shows
the lifetime incidence requiring surgery
is only 1 to 2% this is because there
are far more effective and less invasive
alternatives for each potential benefit
of
circumcision now policy statements from
medical organizations such as American
Academy of Pediatrics heavily influenced
providers and parents however the aap's
policy statement on circumcision
intentionally expired 7 years ago
currently no medical organization
recommends this surgery on healthy
children existing legislation
demonstrates that non- therapeutic
circumcision is both cosmetic and
harmful according to the federal
Medicaid guidelines they Define a
surgery as cosmetic when there is quote
no function impairment present to
address New Hampshire admin code fire
30.05 states that non-covered Medicaid
services include in quote cosmetic
surgery for the purpose of improving
appearance which are otherwise not
medically necessary and pursu to
recently pass NH um Bill uh law 619 the
state inserts an interest in protecting
the health and safety of his citizens
especially vulnerable children including
avoiding irreversible invas procedures
for males that alter biologically
healthy and functional body parts end
quote this bill does not restrict
religious practices or deprive access to
medically appropriate care rather it
ensures responsible allocation of
taxpayer dollars which can be used to
enhance funding for New Hampshire's
Public Health goal of expanding screen
Services as Healthcare Providers and
legislators we have a shared
responsibility to uphold our oath that
Safeguard and natural health and bodily
Integrity of miners
this bill Honors that commitment only
when passing the law thank you for your
time and thank you for your
consideration thank you representative
Weber I'm sorry I didn't get the name of
the organization that you were
representing I do not represent um any
organization I'm here my own time I'm
here my own money okay thank you I'm I'm
sorry I misheard it just said medical
community ah the medical community
uh well is is that appropriate if this
gentleman is speaking as an
individual are you're not representing
any I'm representing myself and um the
training that I've received and um my
experience working with patients okay
thanks I I get that I see okay so be I
just normally when we have something
that they're representing there has been
an author it's it's an recognized
organization with an authorization and I
wanted to make the distinction clear and
I understand you are speaking not only
for yourself but those
who um follow the same guidelines but I
wanted to make it clear that it wasn't
any recognized correct organization
thank you representative palazov thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so in general uh like uh a
doctor uh can a doctor decide uh not to
perform certain surgeries and is there a
risk of backlash from Administration or
facility where it's happening or some
other difficulty with deciding not to
perform certain medically unnecessary
surgeries certainly so that decision is
up to um The Physician themselves their
obligation is to the patient that they
are treating or that they are caring for
um in certain organizations um speaking
with other um Physicians that I work
with there is a lot of pressure that
they continue to perform this surgery
but increasing so more Physicians
recognizing the um the increasing um
literature supporting that there's um
pronounced long and short-term risk are
refusing to perform the surgery but
there are Physicians um willing to do so
follow up uh thank you for uh allowing
me to follow up um my my second question
uh uh is
uh uh sorry let me formulate
it sorry I lost it okay okay thank you
representative TZ thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um I
apologize I could you repeat your
specialty and then if you know how many
circumcisions you've done or how you're
trained to do it like if that's your
area correct certainly so my um
specialty is general surgery essentially
everything below the neck excluding the
bones and the nervous system um with
Testament to training reflecting back in
my medical school and residency um
education now one second was spent on
the education of this part of the body
the natural um function of the forest
skin in terms of whether or not I
perform a surgery myself like many of my
colleagues I work with refuse to perform
the surgery unless if there is a medical
indication and un less of um for those
medical indications less invasive and
more effective treatments have been
tried first
thank you any other
questions representative paza uh thank
you Mr chair uh I wonder if uh a
physician or news helping physician have
enough time uh uh to inform patients
about uh this procedure why why they
believe it's not medically necessary and
what could be complication
uh because uh we want inform consent but
like I feel often like it's just a
checkbox under pressure and there's no
time maybe to uh deliver information
certainly I re uh recently concluded a
two-year study at a major academic U
Medical Center um assessing just that
question then form consent practices
regarding specifically the surgery as
briefly mentioned the majority of
parents and fortunately first time
discussing this topic with a physician
is in an opportune period after birth
this is a period where parents are tired
they're overwhelmed and there's a lot of
commotion it is not an ideal time to
undergo these
conversations um further um the
conversations that are conducted um are
very superficial uh you they do not do
uh Deep dive into the true benefits and
risk both short and long um term parents
are solicited for this particular if you
do not have the surgery done um at our
institution um the average for uh family
who decided not to have the surgery done
they were asked four times after birth
and before Hospital discharge do you
want to have the surgery done imagine
that you are sitting there you are
disted you are tired with a beautiful
healthy child and you keep on getting
asked do you want the surgery do you
want this surgery and you keep on saying
knowing your decision is not being
respected that solicitation that was
ceron for Unnecessary medical
intervention and some Hospital
organizations including the one that I
work at and one that I did research at
they have check boxes to ensure that
parents are asked this
question other
questions okay I'm seeing none oh I'm
sorry representative wber are you a New
Hampshire resident I'm not I'm a
resident now of Vermont thank you yep I
currently work at the University of
Vermont Medical
Center representative Nagel thank than
you Mr chairman thanks for taking my
testimony I I'm really struggling with
what you just said for a lot of reasons
I mean I don't personally I'm a doctor I
don't do anything elect anything but
elective
stuff
um you're implying that patients are
told at the last minute that they're
going to have a circumcision but they've
known they were pregnant for 6 to n
months
um are you saying that these discussions
aren't going on before that correct so
the majority of parents in our study um
was initially around 55% their first
time discussing this topic with a
physician was after birth and before
Hospital discharge this is representing
328 parental survery responses so I have
a f follow up are you suggesting that
the parents were unaware before that
that this was even an option um they
aware that it is an option one of our
key duties as U um as Physicians is to
obtain informed consent largely with
that um we have parental care classes we
have um prenatal sonography Clinic these
are key opportunities for um Physicians
to be engaged but they are not being
engaged in these
discussions other discussion have any
other
questions I don't see any thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is David
Grant from inaction
.org hello so I'm going to tell you a
little bit of my life story within three
minutes okay thank you um uh uh my life
experience as a victim of
circumcision We Exist we should be
considered in these um decisions to be
made
uh when I was young I was sexually
assaulted by a Southern Baptist preacher
years later I was assaulted by a
Catholic priest at the Jesuit Seminary
and Mission Bureau in New York
City both men used their power over me
neither felt that I owned my own body
these men violated my body in a
disgusting attack but they didn't leave
a mark on me by far the worst violation
of my body was the man who circumcised
me the other attacks I rarely have
anything to remind me but every day when
I urinate I have to look at a big scar
on my
penis uh I also suffer from meatal
stenosis which makes peeing painful at
times I have uh several skin
Bridges uh every time I have sex I'm
reminded that my body was downg graded
by someone who never gave me another
thought what he did to me is a permanent
irreversible unforgivable life sentence
that I will take to the Grave lastly I
would like to say to doctors with so
many people finding out every day that
you have performed a painful cosmetic
procedure on them at their most
vulnerable moment in life saying your
parents told me
to as if you were forced to and you bear
no
responsibility saying your parents told
me to is simply no longer valid uh I am
in support of this bill and uh thank you
for
listening thank
you other there any questions
saying none thank you sir thank
you also signed up to speak is Peter
Adler you've got uh five minutes down to
include questions and answers so if your
testimony can just be free that' be
great thank you sir uh good afternoon
esteemed legislators I'm Peter Adler
from the Flatland of Massachusetts I'm
an expert in circumcision ision and the
law and I believe I can help you decide
this matter uh it's a matter of law not
of policy what I'm going to
show as I showed in a 2011 article it's
unlawful for Physicians to use Medicaid
to pay for circumcision and it's
unlawful for states to allow them to do
that um so hopefully we've persuaded you
today that the for skin of the penis is
a natural part of the body and a very
good thing I'm not sure whether it was
mentioned it's the most sensitive part
of the penis and those who have a for
skin do not want to part with it um I
hope we've persuaded you that uh
Physicians don't normally amputate
healthy parts of children's bodies it's
inconceivable that they would cut off a
finger for example um and uh
circumcision it is more accurately gen
male genital cutting like female uh uh
uh genital cutting um
is not medically indicated meaning uh
doctors know it's not uh needed or
desirable as as people have uh testified
it's extremely painful uh risks more
than 50 complications this narrowing of
the urethal opening happens in more than
15% of cases it can be fatal and it
causes psychological harm so um I wrote
an article showing it's unlawful for
Physicians to perform the operation um
the uh doctor said he refuses to perform
the operation um most countries doctors
uh don't do this um it uh it violates
the rights of the child to bodily
Integrity self-determination and
privacy um and the federal and state
equal protection Clause prohibits the
state or makes it unlawful for the state
to protect girls without extending equal
to protection to boys and as somebody
mentioned um there's a lawyer who's
about to bring an equal protection
lawsuit in another
state um so the claim that circumcision
is preventive medicine is false and
fraudulent it does not benefit most
males at all any benefits can be
achieved without it as the doctor said
and importantly boys are not at risk of
these adult
diseases so um it is unlawful for
Physicians to build Medicade for
Unnecessary circumcision surgery in fact
the number one rule of Federal and State
Medicaid law is that this surgery must
be medically indicated and medically
necessary in order to get paid
Physicians lie on the federal and state
reimbursement form they falsely claim
that the surgery is medically indicated
and they use false diagnosis these
Physicians have been defrauding the
children their parents the state and
taxpayers for decades maybe going back
to
1965 and they unjust unjustly enriched
themselves the state has been allowing
Physicians to get away with fraud New
Hampshire is not doing its duty to
review these payments and coverage and
to prosecute these
Physicians um I will wrap up because I
would like to take your questions and
rebut anything that was said also give
the definition of medical necessity in
New Hampshire law I wanted to say that
passing this bill will uh uh save boys
from these risks and harms allow them to
enjoy their bodies as nature intended it
save uh money that can be used for
people who need services and avoid
lawsuits such as happened in
Massachusetts against the state saying
it was on unlawful to use Medicaid to
pay for circumcision thank you I welcome
your questions any questions
representative palazov thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so in your opinion uh what
defines medical NE necessity well
fortunately I don't need to opine I can
cite New Hampshire law hopefully I I
have the citation correctly to uh uh Hew
530.11
and no more costly or other services are
available to provide equivalent
treatment results it's not experimental
or cosmetic so non-therapeutic VI um
circumcision violates every one of those
Provisions um it's not medically
indicated doctors don't use their
medical judgment they take orders from
parents to perform this surgery and as
has been said um I can attest to it
myself I never thought about
circumcising my son when my wife gave
birth the doctor came in and said have
you decided whether to circumcise your
son or not I'd never thought it I was
taken back and my wife was quote out of
it so I was left to make the decision
myself she's a doctor and I knew nothing
about it and he he told me it's not
medically Justified and he said would I
like to circumcise my son for um for
personal reasons I said what do you mean
and he said do you want your son's penis
to match your penis so this is the kind
of arguments that are insane that
doctors are making they really put a
full court press on people to U uh to
say yes to circumcision and they don't
disclose the harms it's a breach of
fiduciary duty other questions
representative Maser yes thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here today did
you say you have a copy of your
testimony that I would be interested in
receiving that if so yes I think it
should have been given to you um if you
got the pile of materials um but it it
is online as well I actually would
sincerely um be most grateful and think
it would help you to read my written
testimony which is uh five pages along
with citations and uh uh I just
summarized it today thank you other
questions you have
it no this is not it okay um you did
pass it around you
said oh okay here it comes all right if
there if there are no questions Mr
chairman may I take uh one minute to
rebut a couple of points that were made
okay yeah as representative Weber um
microphone's on on I'm I'm just going to
remind people that we had a lot of
discussions about having the rules for
everybody be the same right and when we
start giving people extra time Last
Licks rebuttal and coming back that is
to the of other people who have kept to
the rules and I don't care which way you
do it and you run the committee the way
you want to run it but I it it's a
concern to me okay the Representative
makes a good point s and you have you
have given us extensive testimony here
and we do appreciate it and everybody's
had an ample opportunity to ask your
questions so I I think we'll be good uh
and if there are no other
questions I saying none thank you thank
you all
the chair yes I just want to mention
that we will be happy to receive it via
email any rebuttal that you have yeah
absolutely okay sure okay thank
you okay I am having trouble reading
this last name but to David from 34 West
Street in
Manchester is it g loock barlock okay I
wasn't sure but thank
you test test awesome greetings uh
members of the community on this uh
beautiful New Hampshire day uh listening
to the previous testimony I was trying
to decide since many of the points have
been already brought up I think I want
to put this in the context of the of the
medical view of this historically so uh
obviously the history of circumcision
goes way back uh Egyptian c um
hieroglyphic
um but if you look at the Encyclopedia
Britannica up until 1860 was always only
a cultural and religious practice in
1870 that's when you start to see it um
become medical of course at the time
it's the Victorian era they didn't have
a germ theory of medicine they uh uh had
all kinds of views
about sex that we don't have now uh and
uh
they uh saw surgery is the answer to
everything cuz they didn't have drugs uh
as
um as time went on as others have said
it became a a disease in search of a
cure so it would cure masturbation then
it would cure cancer then it would cures
peritura which is not a real disease uh
and by the middle of the 20th century
many of these uh medical benefits had
been debunked when the National Health
uh service was up in the UK in 19 in the
1940s they uh issued a report uh to look
into it to see if if it should be
subsidized uh and covered by their
National Health Services these were uh
came out in the famous uh Garden report
in 1949 which said that uh it's not
medically Justified and so it was
removed the same thing happened in
Australia and New Zealand in the 1970s
in Canada it's more based on a
provincial um uh level so the times in
Quebec where about half of New Hampshire
people come from Quebec if they trace
their An ancestry back never really
adopted it um Ontario and the uh
prairies basically banned it in the 9s
in the United States uh the country
where it achieved the highest
rates uh those rates started to come
down in the 70s you had the famous Dr
Spock who had earlier in the 60s and 70s
that advocated uh routine infant
circumcision uh changed his tune in in
the in the 80s saying that it was no
longer necessary and we've had it
referred to a couple times now the AAP
the AAP is a totally legitimate
organization uh we need organizations we
need free association of people but they
have every in every incentive to have
procedures be covered and paid uh
they're they're an advocacy
organization uh for their members and
the more things that they can be paid
for the better uh when their last policy
statement on this was issued that was in
uh now this was quite a controversial
document because they relied heavily on
non-medical reasons cultural reasons
religious reasons personal reasons
looking like Dad feeding in the locker
room
and just to end very very briefly
uh that policy expired in 2017 and in
the 13 years since then they have not
come up with a good reason why it should
be justified or covered if this advocacy
group can't come up with a good reason
to cover it there is no reason the state
should be subsidizing something that is
not medically necessary as we've well
established by other testimony is not
medically necessary okay thank you any
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Rabbi
Robin Nafi from the Jewish clergy
Association of New Hampshire
thank you sir and members of the
committee as was mentioned my name is
Rabbi Robin Nafi I'm the rabbi of Temple
Beth Jacob here in conquer and I am a
part of and representing the Jewish
clergy Association of New
Hampshire in the Bible specifically gen
Genesis 17:
9-12 God speaks to Abraham the father of
the three monotheistic faiths God says
as to you you and your Offspring to come
shall keep my Covenant such shall be the
Covenant between me and you and your
Offspring every male among you shall be
circumcised you shall circumcise the
Flesh of your foreskin and that shall be
the sign of the Covenant between me and
you throughout the generations every
male among you shall be circumcised at
the age of 8 days for Jews circumcision
is a sacred ritual that goes back
3,000 years
for nearly all Jews it is not merely a
suggestion it is a commandment an
obligation a
requirement unless medically unsound we
circumcise our baby boys on the eth day
of life and when it is medically unsound
we don't abandon the practice we perform
the circumcision when the baby boy is
medically ready Muslims too practice the
sacred ritual of circumcision on baby
boys and usually now on the seventh or
Eighth Day of life it was mentioned in
prior testimony that it would be before
puberty in my speaking with uh a
prominent Muslim in our community
yesterday he assured me that it is done
extremely early now um as I indicated
seventh or Eighth Day of
life this bill as you all know would
prohibit the State Medicaid Program from
covering circumcision of a minor unless
the procedure is deemed medically
necessary the bill goes on to list 14
medical conditions that would fall into
the category of medically medical
necessity and then provides the catchall
of or any diagnosed condition for which
a circumcision is deemed medically
necessary by a physician or other health
care provider licensed in New Hampshire
the bill is called the children's body
autonomy
act speaks to me seems to me that if the
authors and sponsors truly cared about
body autonomy they would not includes
such a lengthy list of medical
exceptions you just leave it to the
Judgment of medical providers
perhaps on reading the bill particularly
reading it from the perspective of being
a rabbi it feels in many ways that it is
targeting the religions Jews and Muslims
in particular for a procedure that is
ritually demanded and ritually
standard this to me is a clear violation
of the First Amendment to the
Constitution as it violates the the free
the right of the free exercise of
religion as such I urge the members of
this committee to vote in expedient to
legislate thank you for taking my
testimony I do have written copies okay
great thank you very much any
questions I Y I'm scar representative
blows up I apologize that's right uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh could you commment
or refute previously received data that
in Israel uh percentage of circumcision
is going down and uh that allegedly even
some religious Jews uh trying to find
some alternative to completely cutting
the for skin but still uh keeping some
part of
tradition two two prior people indicated
the breach Shalom the the Covenant of
Peace as a substitution um for those
those who choose um to not enter into
the traditional ritual of Covenant um it
is an option it is not very um it's not
standard it's not very it's not opted
for very frequently one of the reasons
that the percentage is going down in
Israel is that the population is
becoming more mixed um there are a lot
of foreign workers who come into the
country and remain there um it's not
necessarily A Drop in the Jewish
community um in fact most studies show
that across the world Jews and Muslims
still uh circumcise virtually
universally not completely not we've
heard testimony from um someone who's
Jewish who opted not to circumcise her
son um but virtually
Universal other
questions representative damus and then
representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question so just I guess
for myself um do you believe that the
being subsidized by the government is
something that that is fair for those
who want to have their boy I I
understand what you're saying about the
about the Covenant um but I don't
know how to marry those two
things I would look at it more as the p
as the we don't ask anybody what the
reason is behind their choice for
circumcision whether it's ritual whether
it's um religious cultural medical we
don't ask when parents simply make that
option and by um doing away with
Medicaid fa funds um it is putting a I
believe a burden on those poor Jews poor
Muslims who seek to um seek to practice
their religion and it is their therefore
for creating an obstacle for them to the
practice thank you representative
Weber actually I think your answer to
that question took care of mine as well
thank you very much thank you thank you
other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
again also signed up to speak is
representative Kelly
Penza from straford District 19
thank you Mr chair uh for the record my
name is um representative Kelly Penza
straford District 19 um Rochester Wards
1 2 3 4 and six I testified on this bill
last session and
um I was already pretty knowledgeable in
this subject but after listening to more
than four hours of testimony um in the
amount of hours that I spent on Research
frankly I was um I was pretty horrified
with what's been going on in our
country um and especially over the last
decade I'm going to send you guys all an
article and this article came out in
2021 from an incredible man that was
researching he was having a
son and he wanted to to make sure that
he looked at all the different options
and um and I'm just going to read
because I know you've had a long a lot
of testimony so and it has to do with
the selling of the
forkins which is truly a practice that's
happening throughout the country in with
these hospitals and they're making money
on it and that's the reason why there is
no there's a push there's no informed
consent um because once that stops for
an elective procedure I don't even
understand why that we would be paying
for an elective procedure but in any
case once it stops then this for-profit
entity stops as
well so this
is a name of the company is called organ
um
organogenesis so why the secrecy what
about ethics I question the ethics of
taking the anatomically important for
skim from a healthy baby without his
consent in an extremely painful
procedure for Pro for profit making
purpose and without adequately informing
the parents many of these parents are
using Medicaid insurance and come from
low-income disadvantaged communities
these hospitals have a financial
incentive to perform circumcisions and
then another Financial incentive to sell
the forkins to a for-profit company the
hospitals are then in the role of
providing care to infants and dispensing
medical advice to parents this is deep
troubling conflict of interest to me
while some might argue that obtaining
four skins is no different than
collecting cord blood they are um
mistaken the removal of the foreskin is
a painful is a painful and involved
procedure with a host of potential side
effects even more importantly the
foreskin serves as an important function
in male sexuality in comparison the
umbilical cord must be removed and
discarded as it serves no further Purp
purpose the hospitals that participate
in the Oregon ogenesis program are
conducting thousands of infant
circumcisions are these doctors
encouraging The Cutting of baby boys or
manipulating parents from disadvantaged
communities where otherwise they may
have elected not to circumcise their
son while the written guidelines suggest
the hospital is supposed to avoid
ethical lapses how truthfully are these
policies being followed what training
programs are in place to instruct staff
in requesting parental coop cooperation
and do verbal staff parent explanations
match the written consent forms I know
for a fact that they do not at Dartmouth
Hitchcock especially when money is
involved Oregon ogenesis is one company
of many that may have commercialized
infant foreskin how many more donation
programs by other companies are there
out there hidden by confidentiality
agreements
lastly if all this activity is above
board and conducted under the highest
ethical standards as they claim why the
secrecy like most children's my
instincts are to protect my children we
should never allow the chance that a
child may be exploited biotech companies
should not have the right to obtain a
pound of our children's flesh literally
without our knowledge or
consent thank you thank you any
questions our representative Woods thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I'm very troubled by what you
said that in fact this tissue uh is
being sold with and I guess the
implication and correct me if I had the
wrong implication that the the the
parents do not know that this tissue is
being sold correct the parents do not
know this article has uh pieces of
contract in it it it's it's fantastic it
covers everything it goes from the time
that where he considered it all the way
through uh he is a CEO of a company it's
probably one of the best um um articles
I've ever seen and you know so a lot of
reps are new here on the committee some
that weren't of course the chair and um
representative mour they're familiar
with the testimony from last year um
it's clear that uh they're not telling
our current um hospitals here in New
Hampshire are not telling anyone and so
just so you know there's a lot of the
the tissues that are being sent here
from New Hampshire they go direct to
Boston I have all of that information I
will be happy to to um to give all of
that to the committee follow follow yeah
um I'm I'm very interested in this from
the standpoint this violates every
element of medical ethics and um are
there cases that have reached the court
level I can't imagine that they have not
if in fact this is the what is occurring
uh are there cases that have reached the
court
not that I'm aware of um I'm not sure
there was a a gentleman that that was
here he was a lawyer from New York I
think you guys right remember that last
year there he had a he had a lot of
cases a lot of cases that he had fought
in one um informed consent um you know
of course uh young men that had been um
they're you know in a sense um
permanently disabled from U procedures
and stuff but not going after what we're
talking about but maybe that's something
that uh should happen and it should
happen uh forth with at least giving
people the knowledge parents especially
um informed consent and is very
important about what they're doing with
those
foreskins representative lontine uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh there's one thing
that you said that um and I just want
clarification that um suggest
that babies born um insured by Medicaid
are more likely to have circumcision
than those on private insurance is that
what you said no that's not I read I
don't think so
um I was reading the article so it is um
I can go back to that you can and I'm
going to send it to you anyway um many
of these parents are using Medicaid
insurance and come from lowi income
disadvantaged communities
um these hospitals have a financial
incentive to perform
circumcisions uh like no I don't I guess
it was the question many of these babies
it sort of suggested it was more
than um the other like you're talking
about one population in
particular no I think that was just a
statement in the article
okay representative Paz off thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
uh do do we know when this practice of
uh uh started practice of uh uh selling
uh that
tissue yes so this article talks about
and it gives some dates and it goes back
to like there's some dates of 2014 in
2015 um there's uh um there's skincare
companies things like that that are
using these um they're used for a lot of
different reasons um you know there was
some unfortunately jokes from movie
stars Sandra bulock on um on television
shows Oprah joked about it calling it
penis cream um yeah this is this has
been widely known for at least a good 10
years I don't know how long the practice
has been I think it's been ramped up
um it talks about it in this article um
one force kin can go for as much as
$440 other questions
representative
McLean you you mentioned as well that um
organizations here specifically
mentioned Dartmouth Hitchcock they're
not following or they're violating their
own informed consent
policy do you have examples or anything
that could back that up because that's
pretty
explosive I don't I'm not saying that
there's um I'm just saying that there's
no they're not telling people that
they're using the forkins in selling
them that's what I'm talking about
that's it's I I we wanted an informed
consent Bill last session that didn't
take place um actually the the nurse who
is also a representative that is against
this Medicaid portion of the bill um
came and testified last as a nurse and
that was one of her biggest problems and
wanted that bill to pass because she
felt like her in her entire time working
within the system and I think she's in
NASA um there's absolutely no informed
consent of talking about the the
problems that can you know in Waiting
the 8 days and all of those things like
the biblical away when clotting takes
place so you don't have to inject
vitamin K so there's there's a lot of
different things but there's no really
informed consent that's why we really
wanted to pass that other
Bill other
questions seeing none okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Anthony
losquadro representing the Health Equity
excuse me Health equality
campaign again sir you've asked for five
minutes if you could keep it to three
I'd appreciate it
Health Quality campaign you could put
your microphone on sorry uh my name is
Anthony L squadro I'm the director of
the Health Quality campaign and I
represent the growing CHS Across America
that advocate for higher standards for
the bodily autonomy of children and I
urge your support for this bill
specifically when it comes to medically
unnecessary elective non-therapeutic
infant circumcision or entic it's a
fancy way of saying it doesn't do
anything and you don't need it I
prepared a package of brief but
informative documents for each Committee
Member on the page Marked One There's a
summary of issues that you may find
enlightening especially if you're
unfamiliar with the topic but on the
other hand if you always thought
circumcision was somehow beneficial or
that men wanted this done to them you
might be surprised and I ask you to all
keep an open mind this section covers
how 17 other stat have dropped coverage
and more considering it because it
serves no purpose it covers and this
document also covers complication rates
for the for the practice and it provides
sources on psychological harm resulting
from enti and I
think most reasonable people understand
it's wrong to cut female children's
genitals in fact it's
illegal so therefore it stands for
reason we shouldn't use Public Funding
to male children's genitals either we
should all have equal protection under
the law which the 14th amendment
guarantees to all of us but now some
people will say male circumcision is
different it has medical benefits but
they'll ignore the fact that no American
Medical Association recommends anti
circumcision and virtually all medical
associations around the world
specifically do not recommend it in the
absence of a bona IED medical condition
now I can draw your attention to the
page marked two which is a statement
from the Canadian Pediatric Society and
what they say is the Canadian Pediatric
Society does not recommend routine
circumcision of every newborn
male uh and Canadian Public Health Care
does not cover infant circumcision and
they're doing just fine there there
aren't any Mass public health problems
or religious
and the vast majority of babies in
Canada are being left intact matter of
fact it's only some states in the US
that covers this with Public Health Care
virtually no other country around the
world covers infant circumcision with
their public health
system on page four uh there's a study
from the Journal of Pediatric Urology
which found an
11.5% complication rate based on the all
claims insurance database complications
can include effect bleeding scarring and
so on I ask you to consider the cost of
these complication Corrections which are
called revisions into your cost analysis
and they should be added to the fiscal
note packet F page five of my packet
includes cost benefit analysis from Dr
Rober vanau who's a professor of
Pediatrics Central Michigan University
in the Journal of medical decisionmaking
and he did an analysis if infant
circumcision was more start wrapping up
sir yes sir uh if infant circum C was
more cost effective over the life of a
patient he concluded that it was not
what he said is neonatal circumcision is
not good health policy and support for
it as a medical procedure cannot be
justified financially or medically so
with that I'll I'll wrap up and I'll say
uh I ask that you support this bill and
uh children of people and they deserve
to live their lives with natural intact
bodies thank you very much okay thank
you any questions for gentlemen
not seeing any sir thank you thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on hb994 FN does anyone else wish to
testify seeing no one I am going to
close the public hearing on HB 94 FN
that concludes our hearings for today um
if the committee doesn't object I'm
going to recommend a 10-minute recess
perhaps before we go into executive
session
we've been sitting quite a
while sure
okay okay all right we're going to be in
recess 10 minutes 15 minutes what what
is
the is better okay need to get on to
other
thingses okay so uh we will be in recess
until 3:00 and and then we
convene
e
e e
okay I'm going to
reconvene um number of bills we're going
to consider are proceeding into an execu
executive session at this time uh one
comment to make before we actually be we
start executing bills uh HB
54 uh we are going to I'm going to
appoint a subcommittee to examine that
issue and I am going to appoint the
following members uh representative
David Nagel representative Jim kofalt
and representative Gary Woods uh
representative Nagel will serve as the
chairman of that
subcommittee that is an early bill so um
gentlemen you got be be uh be efficient
and be
fast uh well that would be wonderful if
it could be done that quickly I believe
that the date that it has to be reported
at out which means that we have to have
voted on it is March 8th March 6 6th and
be aware that because you a duly pointed
subcommittee any meeting that you hold
has to be noticed in the
calendar well it's get get it into the
next calendar there are exceptions but
we can talk about by noon the week by
noon on Wednesday the week before you're
going to have it
yeah yeah so it's too late today so week
after after next would be a good time
and get it to the clerk today and then
or or committee Services I
guess yes yeah uh basically you'd want
to let Karen Davis know our committee
assistant should would handle that okay
any questions about HB 54
FN okay moving on HB 58 is the next bill
we would like to discuss today and I
would recognize representative McAn for
a motion uh thank you chair I would move
itl on this
bill and representative delus do you
have a
motion okay do either of you wish to
speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chair um first of all I mean I don't
want to minimize La covid um you know I
know some people that have had it um and
certainly uh representative Thomas's
testimony was compelling but um there
are uh a whole Myriad of illnesses you
know that we could look at and have
commissions on and we already have 300
commissions I think it's not so much a
question of is the issue real as a
question of do we have the bandwidth to
go after it um with the resources that
we have and so I I think um at this
point in time I would recommend itl
thank you any other discussion on the
motion representative palaz off
uh I just uh want to agree and add that
um there uh used to be special committee
on Co response efficacy and uh then
representative G Merchant uh he raised
the question of long Co so um there's a
chance that uh committee will be um
reconvened and uh long Co will be one of
its topics so uh there might not be need
for another commission for that thank
you thank you other discussion
representative mlan could you I didn't
quite hear that what what commission was
that represent what was a special
committee on covid response efficacy and
um uh it's kind of like special
committee but also standing committee
and um there's a push to reestablish it
with long Co being in one of its topics
so there might be
overlapping repres
wber um thank you Mr chairman my my
understanding that that is and I could
be wrong about this but the I thought
the charge on the commission on covid
response was to discuss the quality of
the emergency response there and the
thrust of this committee would be
uh the
economic concerns created by long Co um
I too don't want to minimize the effects
of long covid either for the
individual uh medically or financially
or for society as a whole in the amount
that we lose to that but there are any
number
of uh chronic diseases that have
some or similar aspects to them and then
the other thing was we were actually
handed a fairly comprehensive study by
the New Hampshire uh fiscal policy
Institute I believe uh so I think that a
lot of the ground has been already
plowed um so um without wanting to
minimize the concerns I think I'm going
to vote
against okay thank you
representative Woods um from my
perspective just from the basic science
uh uh perspective I think this is
premature uh the New England Journal of
Medicine just a month ago uh had a very
nice review article uh trying to Define
what is long co uh so I think uh this is
this bill is basically a step ahead we
don't even know the medical community
can't really decide precisely what it is
let alone uh legislate how you're going
to interact but I think we need to stand
back and wait a bit okay thank you other
discussion represent yes representative
thank you um yeah I want to just Echo
what rep wood said um just for just to
disclosure I'm a co-sponsor on this
legislation so I will be voting in favor
of it for that reason but I totally
agree with you that we really need to
actually get it into the correct
category it belongs in and kind of have
a better definition for that and get
that officiated first so um but thank
you thank you any other
discussion okay seeing none uh we'll
move to the vote the mo motion is itl on
House Bill
58 and Mr clerk if you're ready please
call the
roll uh motion is itl so if you vote yay
you are voting for The itl if you vote
no you voting against the itl corre
that's is correct that's correct all
right R merer
yes R
mlan
yes rep
damus rep kofalt
Nagel PA off
yes clerk votes yes
rep Markel
yes rep McGrath
yes rep Weber
yes rep McKay
yes rep Woods
yes R
Sebert
no R TZ
yes R lontine yes
rep
hartnet rep Lucas
yes and rep McDonald
yes vot V is 17 to1 motion passes any
objection to
consent okay all right and next up is
House Bill 370 representative mlan do
you have a motion yes uh thank you Mr
chair I would like to make a motion of
ought to pass on HP
370 uh representative McGrath do you
have a
motion you have a
second okay uh discussion
I'll be very brief Mr chair just
basically kind of repeating some of the
testimony I think there's a real need
here um even though we're only talking
about 10 people um the
uh the the the this is a very limited in
scope I think this is something that is
solvable uh the commission was already
formed and this is a reforming of the
commission the only reason they were not
able to do their work is because they
were formed really at the very end the
members of that commission are highly
motivated to go forward um so this will
not be a commission in name only this
will be a commission in fact that will
actually be able to bring forth I hope a
good solution thank you Mr chair thank
you any other discussion representative
McGrath did you have any comments
or thank you representative Weber I just
wanted to be sure that we had clearly in
front of us the fact that uh some people
who are caught in the interstices
between
uh behavioral crisis and uh intellectual
disability simply can't receive services
and we absolutely have to fix this so
thank you for bringing it Forward is
ought to
pass representative Nagel um I wanted to
in a way second that at our ship State
Health assessment meeting yesterday a
consumer begged us to solve this problem
and cited a number of examples of why
this is a problem and this group has
passion and I think we should let them
do their
job thank you other
discussion okay seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the all the motion is
ought to pass on House Bill
370 Rett merer
yes BR mlan
yes rep damus
rep kopal
yes rep Nagel
yes rep poov
yes clerk votes
yes R marel
yes R McGrath
yes rep Weber
yes rep McKay
yes rep Woods
yes rep CT
yeah rep TZ
yes rep lontine
yes rep
hartnet
yes and rep
Lucas yes R McDonald
yes vot is 18 to0 motion passes thank
you any objection to consent no okay
next up is House Bill 205 FN uh
representative mea do you have a
motion yes thank you Mr chair I motion
to itl on House Bill
205 representative Paz off I second okay
discussion representative Maser yes I
I'll just keep it short um you know
overall
I highly respect um veterans and their
needs and PTSD and all of that but from
what we heard uh during the
hearings um even one of our main
sponsors of all these bills
representative Thomas she said she
tepidly supports this bill um I wrote
those words because I thought that was
interesting um and several others
including the honorable Jerry kerk said
that he didn't support it um and others
so and also seemed like it was kind of
there's a cost shifting aspect to it and
uh so for that reason I I vote itl I
move itl okay other discussion
representative Palazo yeah second this
motion because uh uh of cost shifting
aspect I am ready to work uh um with the
veterans organization how we can uh
improve their access to uh needed um
chemical for chemicals for medical
reasons but uh this uh bill doesn't do
much only $50 for three years but also
it uh shifts cost on some other parts of
the system so I don't think it's needed
thank you thank you any other discussion
representative Nagel um thank you Mr
chairman I I'm actually going to um
oppose the it I I'm on the therapeutic
cannabis Medical oversight board I was
part of that discussion on this bill um
this provoked a lot of thought three
votes and not a single vote passed um so
we were just left to say what we wanted
um and I think representative kerk did
relay that to us um um my initial
thought was actually that I opposed this
and then the more we talked the more I
liked it one of the reasons why was
number one the veterans do not have any
access to therapeutic cannabis through
the VA system they are actually punished
by the VA system for going through it if
they want to get it they have to go
outside of the system I do know a lot of
veterans that do it but I think the
testimony that bothered me the most was
the most common reason that combat
veterans use medical cannabis is not for
PTSD but for pain and the fact that the
gentleman that was representing veterans
seemed unaware of that really bothered
me a lot and and maybe that's a really
rotten reason to oppose this but um I've
seen that in a lot of settings elsewhere
and it really bothers me that people
don't recognize that um um with that
said a lot of the groups that we felt
that were somewhat like veterans did
have access were the veterans don't and
I realize this is a trivial thing but I
think the cough shifting actually is
fairly trivial as well so that's why I
oppose
this okay any other
discussion seeing none the motion before
us
is um moot inexpedient to legisl on
House Bill 205 FN I'll ask the collect
to call the
rooll rep Maser
yes rep mlan
yes rep
damus rep kofalt
yes rep Nagel
no rep poov
yes clerk votes yes
rep marel
yes rep McGrath
yes rep Weber
yes rep McKay
yes rep Woods
yes re Sebert
yes rep tez
yes rep lontine
yes R
Harnet rep
Lucas yes rep McDonald
yes vote is 17 to1 motion
passes any objection to
consent hearing none okay next up is
House Bill 72 uh representative Nagel
you have a
motion
sorry I'd like to make a motion on um HB
72 of a to
pass and I will second that motion sorry
representa did you want a second be glad
to but happy to yield the floor no
representative wber
seconds representative Nagel do you wish
to speak to your motion um I hear over
and over again how we have too many
commissions however I feel very strongly
about commissions that are passionate
about what they do about important
subjects this is an important subject
about increasing access to care um 30%
of my patients live in the North country
and I can't live without tele tella
Health it's really important um I think
that's one of the shin Silver Linings of
covid is the increased access what
became somewhat concerning that I showed
people earlier today was this came from
CMS and which they apparently are going
back to pre-co tah Health rules which I
think is
hopefully not as tragic as it would
appear superficially but because of that
this is an ongoing issue that we really
need to stay on top of and study um
especially yeah we have no control over
CMS per se but we do have control over
what goes on in this state and I think
we need to stay on top of
that thank you representative Woods uh I
would wholeheartedly agree um tele
medicine is one of the sort of shiny
examples of what we can can do with our
technology uh some things have not been
so illustrious with what we've done with
our technology this I think is really
represents one of the real shining
examples of what we can do to help
patients in every Dimension I mean this
is there is an article this week um that
highlighted the business about trying to
have patients not come to the hospital
certain things you can handle at home
by with tele Advanced forms of tele
medicine the ramifications of this are
just tremendous all to the good
basically at this point so I'm really
wholeheartedly in favor of this thank
you representative Weber did you have a
comment and where you seconded it okay
top any other
discussion okay seeing none motion is
ought to pass on House Bill 72 Mr clerk
please call
the r merer
yes re mlan yes re
damus Reb kofalt
yes rep Nagel
yes rep paof
yes clerk votes
no R marel
yes Rett McGrath
yes rep Weber
yes rep McKay yes rep
Woods R
certon yeah rep TZ
yes re lontine
yes rep
Harnet
yes rep Lucas yes R McDonald yes
vote 17 to1 motion
passes and again is there any objection
to
consent
okay okay next up is House Bill
301 and uh representative Weber
has thankfully and graciously drafted an
amendment uh representative Weber do you
wish to move your Amendment for
discussion I would be glad I would be
glad to is there anybody who had did not
get a copy of the amendment because I
have many
extras uh I would like Mr chairman to
offer Amendment 2025
0132 and if there's a second I would
like to speak to it I will second
representative Paz off seconds
representative Weber uh so what this
does is when the bill came to us it was
somewhat unclear and we were hearing a
certain amount of concern
about what the offsite premises might
look like and there was also some
concern about how many off premises uh
sites this might extend to and whether
they could be used by people from other
states and various other things and so
this comes to us from Mr
Simon uh and it specifically says that
each of the atc's may have one offsite
premise and and that premise is going to
be a greenhouse so instead of discussing
what might happen this is very clear
about what's going to happen and I think
with that that may have uh resolved some
of the concerns that various people had
not only here but among law enforcement
and others so I would hope that we would
adopt the amendment and then go on to
adopt the
bill any other
discussion I'm seeing seeing none okay
the motion is ought to pass on Amendment
2025 d01
32h Mr clerk when you're
ready rep Meer
yes rep mlan
yes rep
damis rep kofalt yes rep Nagel
yes rep paa yes clerk votes
yes R marel yes Rett McGrath
yes R Weber
yes R McKay yes rep Woods
yes rep
Sebert
yes rep tez
yes rep lontine
yes rep Harnet
yes rep Lucas
yes Rett McDonald
yes vote is 18 to zero motion
passes okay representative palaza you
have your hand up uh I I would like to
move forward to pass House Bill 301 as
Amendment as amended with Amendment
-132 H okay do I have a
second represent second it I was
assuming I was gonna yeah I'm sorry
go
ahead who wants to do
it okay representative Weber you have no
objection I have no objection and I I
certainly it's not my place to object
anyway I assumed I was going to be
writing the the blur on this but I'm
happy to pass it off so all right
representative Nal second he took it
back what what's this now he took it
back back his
motion yes or no Dave
well you're just gonna just just a
second representative pazo has
representative Palazo put his hand up
too soon he he's writing the report
yes representative palov moved and
representative Nel seconded I don't
right exactly yeah yeah okay
representative Nagel's trying to confuse
us
yes okay so the motion is out to pass on
uh House Bill 301 a HB 301 with the as
amended 03132 H any other discussion uh
if I may uh to speak uh it's a common
sense approach uh that tried in the
states around us and uh amendment that
by representative web makes it it more
tigh and strict uh so there would be no
complain or uh issue issues with zoning
uh uh at the same time uh this approach
would allow to uh save uh uh significant
amount of resources because uh
artificial uh lightning uh uh consumes a
lot of energy and allowing using uh
sunlight uh is a right approach so
please support it okay other
discussion seeing none Mr Clark when
you're ready motion is out to pass is
amended on House Bill 301 rep merer yes
rep mlan yes rep damus yes R kofalt yes
re
Nagel rep poov yes clerk votes yes rep
marel
yes rep Weber
yes rep McGrath yes rep McKay yes rep
Woods
yes rep
Sebert yes rep TZ
yes rep lontine yes rep Harnet
yes rep Lucas yes rep McDonald yes V is
18 Z motion
passes I would move consent okay thank
you and if there's no objection per per
representative Weber's motion we will
put it on the consent calendar wow five
bills in a row on consent and could I
just check I didn't note did we accept
consent for 301 as well thank you we did
yes well that was that was that was it
that was one what's
happening this is just the easy stuff
that gets skimmed off the top yeah we
haven't gotten into immunization and and
eliminating agencies and all that stuff
that's other bills
doing we're just clearing the decks
here we are assuming there's not going
to be a Minority Report on those is
that what's that no yeah I don't have
any minority reports we can't go on
consent if there's a minority rep I
don't okay so it's been a good day we
got a lot done and um I thank everybody
for their hard work uh we do have our
bills scheduled for next uh week uh next
Wednesday once again anything else to be
U actually I should let me close the
executive session before I say too much
more uh that that concludes all of the
bills that we had planned for the
executive session again we we have bills
scheduled as as u usual for next
Wednesday starting at
9:30 and uh
any questions for the committee before
we
adjourn uh we'll get back to you on that
you know not not sure yet check your
email okay every day okay please thank
you anyone else no okay thank you
everyone we stand
adjourned
e e